there's no time 13 o clock hey it's
episode 100 yep we're here - here's the
show you've been waiting for and look if
your list if you're watching this on
YouTube then look you can see are a
delightful faces yes
100 episode I know right unfortunately
if you're listening to the audio version
then you can't see our delightful faces
and you will just have to imagine them
like usual we've already actually
recorded most of the bulk of this show
it's already indicated it's already in
the can you will see it shortly we have
special guests Shana and Eric and
Demonica from battle glitter right they
spent pretty much an entire day with us
drinking recording talking about creepy
disappearances horrible murders of
entire families so you know it's a good
time we're do the shadows that we would
normally do for a normal show so we're
gonna head and do those now because we
couldn't do them then yeah true right so
that's we're gonna do now just really
briefly because this is our 100th
episode I mean we started this show what
back in summer of 2016 and we really
appreciate everybody that's kind of come
along on this ride with us we didn't
really know what to expect we just kind
of started we've 13 o'clock - you know
is a fun thing for us to do and we
picked up a lot of heavy hitters in
terms of patrons - a lot of 20 $25 a
month people you know it we're really
we're really grateful for you guys
support oh yeah and really like any any
support you can give us any just like
giving us a like you know sharing a
video we supporting us on patreon
anything is sending us messages giving
us topic ideas and stuff it's all of
that is really really appreciated yeah
we make good friends to the show too
we really have and there's like all over
the world you know people are sending
their all excited about it and that's
like that's so cool like I never really
thought that would happen and so I think
that's really awesome and I think the
hundredth episode is a good time to
reflect on that mm-hmm now the only
thing the only other thing I want oh
here we're look at look at his yeah
that's my bucket bucket I think I
mentioned this Auggie I think I
mentioned this on the other part of the
show too that we already recorded look
he made me one too
but this kilo though this is a bucket of
Bloody Mary with pickle juice with
pickle juice in it should try it it's
really fantastic it's magical recipes ah
yeah yeah it's really good like maybe
some people might think it's gross but
you use the hot VA I think a hot and
spicy v8 you want to you want to use a
little bit of wishes or sauce and then
put some pickle juice in it along with
the vodka I don't know if I want to say
that like on category the pickle juice
makes everything but what about an ice
cream Jenny what about that well
actually in the original recipe they
said make ice cubes out of pickle I do
pickle juice and I was like oh that's a
good idea that's like I'm in sorrow I'm
too lazy I'm just gonna pour it right in
there
but yeah so basically our same shoutouts
as usual please support the show on
patreon if you would like to which is
patreon.com slash 13 o'clock podcast or
go to our blog which is 13 o'clock
podcast wordpress.com and there's link
in the sidebar to a PayPal account also
check out our last movie review which
was tobe Hooper's 1985 yeah it was weird
man it was a very weird movie I'm
surprised I'm surprised it doesn't have
a bigger headache following had that
girl running around but ass naked
through half the film though you know
how could that a flop so the entire the
entire male half the entire male half of
our listenership just what go check that
you should want to get that on blue very
nice perky titties but anyway yeah you
know all about boobs
monsters you can't really see them
because I'm not yeah and plus I'm
wearing a t-shirt I'm not gonna take
your suggestion
yes ideas this idea I forgot how it went
it was like what do you mean how it went
it was a very simple idea send us 75
bucks you can [ __ ] pop them babies
out on [ __ ] pornhub that's what I
mean and now plus I'm gonna show up on
porno of where they belong pornhub lift
us up where we belong yeah I'm singing a
song about titties on pornhub okay so
the only reason like we wanted to record
this little intro and we also had to
during our 10 family massacres segment
our night segment the audio got [ __ ]
up like for some reason like the tent
segment was fine the night segment the
audience are going yeah and like pretty
much the whole thing was [ __ ] up and
we're gonna fix it though so we're just
gonna record though so that's why when
you're watching the show yeah it's all
of us looking like in different outfits
and yeah it's different people involved
yeah and we're talking about that
because all of the [ __ ] up with bats and
[ __ ] and everything that's in the sink
all kinds of stuff and then suddenly
hears us again with our smiling faces we
show you guys my blu-ray collection
where all the blue let brude blu-rays
live yeah bro I know so uh hopefully you
guys enjoy this little video intro like
I said if you're listening to the audio
version obviously you're gonna have to
imagine what we look like so or just
look us up on Google why do I want to do
oh man said I could he's giving me smoke
for like atmosphere and you know it's
kind of like you know like like Luke I'm
your father actually it never he that
little boy never says
man said I could he never does I killed
me when I went says that when we did
that episode and I scrubbed back through
the whole entire episode to get an audio
clip of him saying that and he never
says that no it is man said it'd be okay
he says man said it would be okay man
said it would be fun yeah and man said I
don't have to listen man said listen T I
like that one too the man said I don't
listen to you I was gonna put that on
the shirt but then I thought that it was
too long yeah yeah a little bobble
Bobble yeah a little bit would've been
good so you know well because the thing
is we say man said I could yeah it's
it's more succinct they didn't say
exactly the show but [ __ ] it alright so
that'll do it for this introduction
please enjoy the very drunk show rest of
the show we're not that drunk in it I
don't think um no no not really no it's
just normal
yeah it's just our normal level so
please enjoy 100th episode this is the
100th not that not the 98 not the 99 is
the 100 is so exciting yeah it is it is
I can't believe that we've actually done
a hundred of these things when we have
guests with us tonight this is Shauna
and Eric good friends of ours
this is Demonica and this is Demonica
their baby we're gonna do a bunch of
different things what's one of the
things we're gonna do this what else
yeah this is kind of gonna be like sort
of a variety type show since it's our
100th episode and we had so many people
request that we do video because we
don't usually so we said well we'll at
least do video for part of this episode
yeah you know we're probably have to
make certain edits so when you see like
stills pop up or achieve
we're like sitting there yeah but if a
few guys are if you guys are ready go
ahead and roll what you have to roll you
know of course I got my favorite JIT
famous jar here yeah now you got a kilo
it's not too key let's Kela do you guys
do you guys see how ridiculous just
joking ridiculous look at how [ __ ]
ridiculous that is it's crazy and that
is your fourth one she's rad Nami
I think she's me this is my fourth one
bit C minor small minor small one make
this [ __ ] up as we go along I definitely
didn't really buy it at all so you know
don't don't get mad but you know people
seem to like that though they seem to
like that you know when we just totally
go ask well when you go off-script
because I don't have a script I'm just
making this up that's what I mean I'm
the only one that has the script is what
do you think what do you think is good
what you drink Kona fire rock pale what
you guys I'm never drink but I'm
drinking if I drink I drink stouts okay
yes what you're hearing there is pure
Brockton it's from Boston you know you
[Laughter]
right yeah and also we have to introduce
the song baby well we have a thing
called battle better we make what you
bring her up to the camera yeah you made
that jacket right yes yeah you make the
jacket that you were
[Applause]
yeah we found a Facebook battle twitter
cool so you want to begin the show yeah
like I said guys oh I I totally did not
really prepare a lot for this at all and
I'm kind of drunk already she'd been
drugged but yeah well no I'm good all
right we all
[Music]
you
and like I said I've had several
requests to do more creepy
disappearances yeah we did a show before
and I think we did five episodes on
there I think we maybe did Tara calico
and Laura Murray and some of the more
famous ones so I wanted to do another
ten of those all right so some of these
like I said don't don't get all up my
ass I'm just telling you ahead of time
because some of these are very
complicated okay and I took a lot of
notes but there's like a lot of notes
and so I have to kind of go through
these you know anything and like I said
we're filming this in our living room
we're at our own private bar at our
estate so so we might have things have
been like for example one of the cats is
running around over there yeah jumping
on top of the washing machine you know
the ice maker might do some [ __ ] so you
know it's very normal
[Laughter]
[Music]
we're ready to go all right so let's
talk about this first can cats are
fighting
oh no that is [ __ ] alright so this first
case so we're gonna talk get your books
I can't read okay I'm over here alright
so the first case we're going to talk
about like I said the first top 10 we're
gonna do is more creepy disappearances
so let's talk about the case of Asha
degree now this happened she was
actually born in 1990 she went missing
in 2000 or when she was 10 years old the
creepiest thing about this now she's a
um you know she's a very little girl her
family were kind of religious and they
were kind of one of those family they
didn't have a computer in their house
like they were you know they they didn't
really want the out
Side world influencing them they were
very into the church and stuff and so
it's funny because well not funny but
there was a quote from her mom or her
dad where she said you know Oh every
time you turn on the TV you just see
pedophiles trying to get little kids
through the internet hold on what year
was this mm oka so yeah so they were
kind of one of those families who are
like well we just want to keep
everything like you know just keep it
within the church and the family we
can't have at a computer or anything
like that and the the kids seemed
alright with this I mean they were very
active in their church they were very
active in their school and whatever now
the weird thing though is that on
Valentine's Day of 2000 for whatever
reason the little girl she would she was
acting totally normal that day she went
to bed now her dad says that he thought
he heard her bed creak or something but
he checked on the kids like several
times over the night like I think the
last time he checked in was like 2:30
a.m. or something cuz I think he
actually worked at night so he checked
on them when he got home and it was
totally fine sometime around 4:00 4:30
a.m. the little girl got out of bed got
her book bag which she presumably had
packed a day or two before with stuff
and left the house and so they see
you're like a several motorists like saw
her like walking away and they said the
weather was like [ __ ] II was cold out it
was warming and there's this little girl
like well she's ten years old and she's
like walking along the side of the
highway or whatever with a book bag so
one motorist actually you know it's like
four or five in the morning one motorist
actually you know saw her and he was
like what the hell so he turned around
to help her out and when she saw the car
stopping she took off into the woods
yeah dr. perv coming and that was the
last time that anyone ever saw her huh
now no one can figure out because her
mom was like you know she was scared to
leave the house she was scared of dogs
she was scared of other people it's like
you know she never really went outside
or went outside the yard or anything why
would she just like suddenly pack up all
her [ __ ] yeah and leave run away
so but she's much younger now at first
that was the thing they thought because
obviously it was something that she had
planned yeah because she had put her
clothes in her little book bag and stuff
and taken off but they don't know if it
was entirely her idea or if somebody had
gotten to her and told her that she had
to you know come there meet them or
maybe she went off of them with some
boyfriend if she's awful little though
it just seemed really really weird and I
you know it's like her parents were just
kind of like why would she why would she
do that it really never found the body
no the only thing they ever found like a
couple years later I think it was a
couple years later they actually found
when they were doing construction in
this one area they found her backpack
like buried or something and it was in a
plastic bag hmm like but the only thing
they ever found like when they you know
when they went out and looked for all
they found like they found like a
barrette that was hers you know like a
little like a marker or something like
out nodes but it must have been but the
thing you know did somebody get her you
know did somebody tell her to leave the
house at hey come meet me here or
something bad will happen or did she
just decide to leave on her own and then
somebody got hurt I wasn't born I wasn't
a coincidence
yeah she was meeting somebody a new
doctor yeah that's like that's like
really bizarre and it's really sad
because um you know her family obviously
has kept up a vigil and they actually
have a big they bought a big billboard
where she ran off into the woods when
that guy in the car stopped to help her
there she was running off to meet
somebody and then that guy faked her
death you know me by burying her bag
making it look like he knocked her off
so they wouldn't look for could be that
she switched houses maybe she's living
with some other guy that's pretty weird
though I mean for a ten-year-old kid and
particularly for what was a weird world
we live it but I mean particularly one
like
a little girl that was so sheltered
evidently I might meet him that might
have made her an easier prey that's kind
of what I'm thinking because that's the
thing like if somebody like what if
somebody approached her like so what if
some weirdo like approached her at
church because they were super like into
their church so what are some weirdo
pressure Church I'm white and it's
likely somebody from church that's what
I'm thinking they're like oh well I'm
gonna I'm gonna kill your mom unless you
come I don't that's what it was yeah I
think it was something like you'd be
better off over here with me you know
I've been that kind of deal maybe it was
a guide his 20s may have had that kind
of pedo leaning of course you know
amanda peet oh yeah uh you know he was
just like when did you come and move and
move in with me well you know we'll have
a lot more funny like to listen to that
time to do yeah yeah and you know then
they he staged their death yeah that's
pretty weird but yeah that's just what
I'm thinking so like I said they never
found the body
no they didn't I would think that they
would have a private found a body by now
there's a chance she's alive probably
pretty good yeah actually the last um
well according to Wikipedia the last
lead that the FBI got was in May of 2016
and evidently a witness came forward
later on and they said that they thought
they had seen her getting into a dark
green in early 1970s Lincoln Continental
or possibly a Ford Thunderbird and this
was along the same road where she was
seen by multiple
motorists but that's the last lead
they've gotten they've searched that
whole area many many times and have not
found anything like I said except for a
couple of little things that were like a
weird everyone's still alive I just do
it does happen I mean they you know
alive it does happen I mean it has
happened before where somebody got
kidnapped and then they got kept as a
sex slave for like 18 years or some [ __ ]
you know it's it's rarer usually they'll
she don't have to deal him I got this
idea that it was a relationship that's
what I think I don't know I think the
girl got kind of if she was older I
might lean toward that but because she
was so young I don't know I don't know I
mean the FBI kind of thought they're
like oh well she was probably just a
runaway but they're like man
II there like you don't usually see kids
runnin away until they're about 12 and
operty yeah
that's pretty young you know we don't
know what was happening at the house
though that's yes we don't know what was
happening but yeah anything could have
been happening sure she was that I'm out
of here
but yeah so that was a pretty weird case
all of these as far as I know pretty
much all of these are still unsolved
they don't know where any of these
people are so okay this one is from 1965
here's this woman named Mary shot well
little she's 25 years old she works as a
secretary she has just gotten married
like six weeks before so it's
mid-october it's October 14th her
husband has gone out of town like on a
business trip which had which he had
planned so everybody knew about it
everything now Mary she goes and has
dinner with a co-worker of hers and then
she was acting totally normal
8:00 p.m. she's going toward her parked
car which was a 1965 Mercury Comet and I
think that was the last time anybody
ever saw her she didn't show up for work
the next day
so her employer calls and there's nobody
there so they go to the Lenox Square
Shopping Center where she had eaten
dinner with the friend the night before
and they find her car there and inside
the car was folded up a pair of women's
underwear a slip and a girdle very
neatly folded a bra was lying on the
floor board alongside a stocking which
had been cut by a knife her car keys
purse and all the rest of her clothing
were gone there were traces of blood on
the undergarments and throughout the
vehicle along with an unidentified
fingerprint in the blood on the steering
wheel but the amount of blood was not
large enough to suggest any sort of
life-threatening injury they said it
could have been a nosebleed
yes punched her right
they actually her and her husband had
they kept a mileage log on the car and
they were able to determine that there
were 41 miles which were unaccounted for
now here is the weird thing though the
her gas card was used later on like the
next day the first time it was used
happened in the middle of the night in
Charlotte which was where Mary Shotwell
was from originally and then 12 hours
later it was used again in Raleigh and
the credit slips had hurt what appeared
to be her signature on them hmm now they
said the weird thing is that in they
interviewed both of these gas station
attendants yeah and both of them said
well one of them said that he had been
that she that Mary had been there and
she had been in the company of a man who
seemed to be controlling her and would
not make eye contact the second gas
station attendant said that she was in
the company of two men and said she was
behaving strangely like they weren't
allowing her to talk so they said it was
kind of weird though because it had been
it's like 12 hours from between when the
guests you know when the gas station
attendant saw her even though those
cities are only three hours apart so you
know they first they looked into the
husband and stuff like that but he'd
been out of town he was on a business
trip he didn't seem super worried that
she was gone which they thought was a
little suspicious but he passed a
lie-detector test all this other stuff
and you know they said Mary hadn't
complained about him or anything they'd
only been married for like six weeks her
husband actually later got a ransom call
asking for $20,000 for her return and
the caller said you have to go to this
particular overpass and there will be a
sign there that's gonna have further
instructions on it so he went there and
there was a piece of paper like taped
onto this side but there was nothing on
it it was blank so yeah a test yes they
were watching that was now some of her
co-workers claimed that a few weeks
before she disappeared she'd been
getting a bunch of phone calls at work
that seemed to upset her and
also she had gotten a dozen roses that
worked from a you know admirer and this
also seems to upset her so then there
was this other woman who she told the
police that she had been in the parking
lot where Mary's car was found on the
same day that Mary disappeared and she
said this guy with a brown crew cut came
up to her and like knocked on her car
window and told her that her back tire
was low but it wasn't so they don't know
if this is some dude that's just like
cruising through this parking lot like
picking people up or if there was some
kind of plot to get her later on there
was a there was a guy that was in prison
in Georgia who had you know an unrelated
case and he said that oh I know two guys
who had been given $5,000 apiece
to kill her but he didn't have any
reason likewise I'm jailbird [ __ ]
right see that's what I mean so yeah the
FBI were just like okay they didn't
really take it seriously the creepiest
thing about this well one of the
creepiest things about this case so
after Mary disappeared this other girl
obviously had to take over her job
because she was gone and that girl got
murdered to jam
did they find out who did that um I
think that now this girl she was 22
years old it was it was year it was a
couple years later it was 1967 yes so
her name was Diane shields and she was
actually she left work she disappeared
and then later she was found dead in the
trunk of her vehicle several hours later
suffocated with a scarf and a piece of
paper from a phone book shoved down her
throat so nuts nothing was she wasn't
raped there was no no robbery nothing
like that so they don't know if those
two were related probably not but that
really does seem creepy that she took
over that woman's job and then she got
murdered to a little while later it
sounds
this sounds like somebody that knew her
this might have bad guys they said that
she was getting to stir sheep yeah it's
like a stalker it sounded like a stop
maybe like an ex yeah must have been
yeah and for some reason she couldn't
tell her husband right yeah
might have been now there there are also
some investigators that suspect that she
left voluntarily and staged the scene as
possible which is possible disappearance
ran off with a new man
but yeah so like I said it seems kind of
strange they don't they had very Maribel
[ __ ] yeah and that's kind of extreme for
a woman that doesn't have children she
didn't have children did she uh
no she was on from kids you can run for
my husband easy you just say I'm out of
here
yeah I mean I was harder back then sure
but like yeah it does only have to stage
a disappearance that leave the husband
yeah I'm always kind of like like I know
I know some people do do that but it's
like a lot of trouble I'll make it look
like somebody punched me in the face and
abducted me yeah but really yeah I don't
know I'm not buying it I kind of feel
like you know if this [ __ ] that her
co-workers were saying was true about
her getting all these weird phone calls
and stuff and getting roses and all that
then I'm kind of making probably a
stalker she was dating somebody behind
there her old man's back yeah my psycho
and he and his boys said we're gonna
we're gonna take her and then we're
gonna hold her for ransom
you know she ain't going out with me so
let's make some money off this there's
something like that something like that
yeah now okay so this third case so
that's something I'm blaming the victim
hello yeah nah it's just I'm just I'm
just talking about likely it's a
likeness yeah
like that first little girl that
disappeared I'm not saying her parents
are doing bad to her I'm just saying we
don't know what was going on in that
house well yes [ __ ] about when kids
leave something's going on in the house
it may not have been anything serious
she just you know did well when you're
ten it's exactly the way or some [ __ ]
[Laughter]
all right no so
okay this third case this is actually
kind of famous because this kid was
actually one of the first kids that
appeared on the back of the milk cartons
no yeah this was Johnny Gosch gosh
born in 1969 disappeared in September of
1982 and he was 12 years old and he was
actually a paperboy and he was last seen
picking up his newspapers very early in
the morning going his route then later
on his parents started getting phone
calls to all these angry peoples like
hey where the hell's my newspaper yeah
and they went and found his little wagon
that was all full of newspapers but he
was gone so the crazy thing about this
one is that now not so I mean obviously
the kid was probably abducted right I
mean you know they probably just took
him right off the street
his mom Noreen seems to think that he is
still alive
and that he got kidnapped to be like in
a child sex ring or you know it was
pornography 1982 she claims that many
years later when Johnny Gosch was an
adult when he was like 27 that he came
to her house with another guy but the
other guy was like not really letting
him talk and I think I heard of this
yeah it's a pretty famous case yeah so
like I said I'm not sure because okay
and this is a terrible thing to say
like her you know her kid got kidnapped
and everything but she sounds a little
bit nutty a little bit but if some of it
could be
I don't know you could steal a kid from
another person right yeah I'm just
saying and it sucks and it sucks that
her kid is gone and she didn't know what
happened to him but she claimed many
years later that a 27 year old Johnny
Gosch came to her house and that there
was another guy with her and so she
thought that he had been taken into this
huge like pedophile ring so she started
she even like um you know testified
before Congress and [ __ ] like that about
I mean they did take some of her [ __ ]
seriously there was some kind of
pedophile ring they didn't read into it
but the FBI are kind of like E and her
ex-husband because I think the husband
divorced her later on he was kind of
like I don't know if that ever happened
like I don't know if that right so and
the problem likely yeah God being
missing that long that he's still alive
yeah I mean we've done again it's
impossible but I don't know how long
stuff's rumored and a lot of stuff came
true you know about weird even even
pedophile rings inside Hollywood and
that was true you know and that's could
be true but I have to say that you know
one of the things that makes me kind of
doubt it a little bit is that she says
that somebody left photos on her
doorstep of three boys or like tied up
and she says that one of them was him
but then later on when they investigated
they actually found out that this
photograph it was just three boys like
[ __ ] around they were like they've
thought they were being Houdini and they
were gonna scare and all this other kind
of stuff like so so was the photo was
investigated yeah we'll see I don't know
if it was but she claimed that it was
and she's like oh here's the photograph
and I have it but I'm starting to not
believe this so yeah so evidently the
FBI looked into it and said no that is
not a criminal photo that was just three
kids we've identified these kids you
know that's not your son so but she
still think thinks that it is okay so I
you know I don't really know and like I
said I don't know if this kid is still
alive now the weird thing too is that
and that I've been in 2006 now she has
actually self-published a book
called why Johnny can't come home about
you know how he's gotten all mixed up in
this child porn ring yeah and they're
not letting him contact her or anything
I've just got to say that on the surface
that sounds like a motherly fantasy that
the boys yeah it does kind of sound like
a mess really
and it's sad it's sad that that were
there you know and I'm not saying you
know it's not impossible that that's
very but it's very very very unlikely
and yeah but it's understandably the
same thing yeah it's understandable that
like if your twelve-year-old kid goes
gets abducted for Christ's sake
I mean you're gonna hold out hope yeah
that they're still alive of course and
it's happened before they've been
abducted and then they've been under the
influence of some pedo for [ __ ] five
ten yeah it's an eerie surface they come
back it's happened but it's very rare
yeah very rare I mean you know so I'm
not saying that it didn't happen in this
case but it just it just seems very
unlikely he did a brainy debris you know
it's like I thought there was another
thing to you where like another paperboy
got kidnapped oh there was that was in
1984 there was another paper boy named
Eugene Martin and he got he got abducted
from the same area this was in Des
Moines Iowa if I didn't mention that but
yes so he disappeared also delivering
newspapers on the south side of Des
Moines so sucks yeah so it could be it
could be that somebody was targeting
boys of that age in that particular area
you know what and I gotta say this since
I've been working on volume two of the
faceless villain which I swear to God it
will be out by the end of summer it's
like it's so long you guys it's gonna be
like six seven or maybe hey but I don't
like I don't know if this is just
because Iowa keeps better records but
holy [ __ ] Iowa it's like they have so
many unsolved murders they're anxious
do in Iowa though not maybe that's what
it is what I'll be getting I said I
don't know like I keep getting the same
states in the same cities like turning
it up and I was like is this just
because they keep better records or is
it just because they have more of this
horrible [ __ ] happen it could be a
combination of both it could be a
combination of things because it's it
seems like every time I go through the
case is like looking I'm like [ __ ] it's
Iowa again again it's Iowa and like you
know I think and I know and I was
talking to I was talking to one of our
fans on YouTube about London Ontario
which you think would be you know it's
Canada they're chill and everything like
that but in the 60s it was kind of like
the serial killer capital there were
they had like three or four the [ __ ]
or what and then the plus there was a
bunch of other random murders yeah
there's like a whole there's a whole
book about it called I think it's called
murder city what and I was and I've been
reading it like I'm lying
oh it was a nexus of [ __ ] up murders
oh they think that it was because
they're like well the city had just it
had been you know it's it's a fairly
large city it's like it was like three
hundred thousand people at the time but
it had been a little bit isolated but in
a only just me take the baby baby but it
it only just opened up because of the
highway and plus it's like right in
between Detroit and Toronto so they kind
of think well maybe if you were just
like passing through they're like but
but so so many of like little boys
little girls woman's like it's
unbelievable unbelievable there were
just so many like it tapered off later
on but it was like in the early too
early to mid 60s it was like crazy so
like Juno Juno with the alien
aliens okay it was like it's like a
concentration of alien it's weird but
that's what but because of the whole
thing with London Ontario I got super
interested in like geographical murder
profiling because that's a thing which I
didn't really know I mean we're from
Brockton we know that they have like all
these mathematical formulas or it's like
we can actually pinpoint like if there's
all these serial murders in the area we
can pinpoint like the most likely area
where the dude lives yeah it's like some
mathematical equation I can well I mean
they can it's you know it's not like oh
he lives right here in this house but I
mean they it's likely in the general
area you know the route they're taking
where they're probably biofuel and it
has to be they have to take into account
where they took the people from where
the bodies were found all this one was
three girls at once yeah yeah at some
point we need to find baby cookie our
kids that we thought we lost earlier oh
my god you guys I gotta sell this story
so they came over like early you guys
came at like three or four o'clock this
afternoon right so we've been here all
day and watching movies and cooking and
stuff and so I'm thinking the cookie is
I haven't seen her all day I mean she
would play with the other cab yeah we're
playing with the other cat Beijing and
you know want to be equal opportunity
cat time right so I'm just like where's
the baby cuz it's like usually she just
I mean you know it's daytime so she was
just lays in there and sleeps on the bed
we cannot find that little kitty
anywhere and then tom is like maybe I
let her out and I'm like I don't
remember you letting her out but even
then it's like we know so we go all
around the house where did I swear to
god we like we're in ruther house
calling her I mean we were we were
really recruiting hard for her but she
was just [ __ ] off yeah convinced that
she was out on her little [ __ ]
mission yeah probably playing with
sandhill cranes and [ __ ] oh she does
love this Anna
like put their wings up like that she's
like oh [ __ ] that [ __ ] okay about yeah
we were all around looking for that
little [ __ ] yeah okay I was I
was like look I don't think she's
outside but it's like when she I'm like
did she get locked in a given it made
Eric outside of like we can postpone
this like we have to we have to find the
cat really bad but I'm like I have to
know where that cat is yeah yeah I have
to know where we wanted to know to at
all times and do you know I would say we
looked through the house everywhere
eighty times like if it's Birds I went
to akattak that looks the dryer I don't
even know this yeah I look behind the
dryer I don't even know this house do
you know where that little brat was she
was all curled up behind my computer
monitor the baby in my she's tiny where
you going baby
maybe later you'll be more compliant man
she's like I don't want to be on TV
lineal or daddy so yeah okay so are we
getting back to this left we have to
keep the show roll all right nowadays of
the s-hook Judge Michael in this short
when we're watching a tease videos in
the background said I don't think you
guys can see it but when I was before
the bathroom Windham is honors nobody
street
yes tiny tiny little like bubblegum
colored shorts on double layered sock
yeah nobody I do like that song though I
admit alright so what was i doing okay
so this was actually this was three
girls Julian mostly Rachel talika Lisa
Renee Wilson now this was a couple days
before Christmas 1974 Nathan eight
wouldn't crimes happened right before
rain and this one is like this is kind
of like Fort Worth Fort Worth Texas the
three of them now Rachel she was 17 but
she was already married even though she
was still in high school to Texas yeah
she had a card her friend Renee was 14
now Julian Mosley was she were married -
no I don't think that very much I'm
sorry yeah but uh Julian Mosley she was
nine I think that she lived across the
street from Renee she's been in that
branner yeah no I don't think I was like
surprised I was like 17 wow that's yeah
although might you know my mom got
married when she was 18 so okay and she
had me when she was 18 well you know as
well so Julian is nine she's kind of
they don't know her all that well but
she lives across the street from one of
his relatives now like hey we're gonna
go to the seminary south shopping center
in Fort Worth Texas and we're gonna do
some Christmas shopping and they never
came the creepy thing was that they
found their car like evidently they went
and they bought a bunch of stuff they
had put some clothes on layaway and
stuff and they had all these like
Christmas presents and packages and
stuff and at some point they came back
to the car and put the stuff in the car
and locked this stuff in the car and
then they don't know where they went
so yeah they never found that books yes
so and another creepy thing too is that
one of the I think the 14 year old had a
boyfriend
and she was all excited about that and
he was supposed to come with them but
then he didn't at the last minute
because he was like oh my friend is sick
I have to go visit him so I mean the
girls were seen in the stores you know a
bunch of people saw them in the mall and
stuff so it must have been at some point
after they went out to the car and put
their stuff in the car now the weird
thing is that like a little while later
they were like well maybe they all just
ran away even though they didn't really
know the nine-year-old all that well and
they didn't have any reason to run away
really
but then Rachel's the oldest one her
husband she got he got a letter in the
mailbox
and it said Thomas H or Lika
like it was addressed to him but she
called him Tommy though but then up in
the you know the return address somebody
had just written Rachel you know I mean
like scrawled it mm-hmm
there was no city name like the postmark
it was just kind of blurry so they
weren't entirely sure where it had come
from it had been stamped it had been
stamped on the morning that it arrived
but the paper inside said I know I'm
going to catch it but we just had to get
away we're going to Houston see you in
about a week the car is in Sears upper
lot love Rachel but he did not believe
that was from her and nobody else in the
family did either
so somebody sent this [ __ ] to their
house saying that the girls were like oh
yeah we just ran away we'll be back in
the wings
sitting up damn run away they will go
and do his Christmas shopping everything
for them eggs and family then it will
run away exactly it's like why yeah it's
like why why would you go out and buy a
bunch of Christmas presents leave them
in your car and then write a story oh
yeah we bought presents but we're all
peas
later if they really were going to
Houston why did they take her car jerks
they just left it in the parking lot
with a bunch of Christmas cards and then
like rhoda letters oh yeah so yeah I
hate you whoever you to whoever took
those [ __ ] girls yeah all of these
people [ __ ] me I hope you're not a
viewer he could be an overall in trouble
the creepy thing too is that mean and
obviously these these girls have never
been found but here's the thing while
they were looking for them they found a
bunch of other skeletal remains of some
other people like in 1975 skeletal
remains of a girl and a woman were found
near San Antonio but it wasn't them and
also there was this was also this was a
1976 they were doing the oil company was
was digging some stuff up in a blog and
they found a bunch of human bones too
but that was also not that boy yeah and
then there was 1981 they found skeletal
remains of three girls but not them I
don't know who those girls it's not that
Ted Bundy type [ __ ] around there
doing I kind of feel like maybe Ted
Bundy killed a lot more people yeah yeah
thank because I was just writing about
it about that right time I was just
writing about a case the other day that
sound bear is very Ted Bundy ask even
though they asked him about it he said
now that wasn't me
hmm well Ted Bundy didn't he never liked
to admit again to admit having killed
any underage girls and they know he did
kill some underage girls so he had a
tendency not to want to talk about
underage girls yeah and those women
sounded underage sir yeah well two of
them were keys to have more so 94
totally lied about it that sounds like a
like a Ted Bundy style crime well I mean
that's gonna be some like they must it
was education our Africa
I'm kind of thinking they had to have
been herded into a van or some [ __ ] like
that like in the parking lot of the
balls that it was that intent about his
territory it was text it was Fort Worth
Texas he was mostly neutral Northeast
mostly right when he was from Vermont
and then I think he [ __ ] her on in
California for a while yeah okay yeah it
wasn't him I'm pretty sure he's from
Vermont though originally because I was
writing about a murder the other day
that they sounded very much like his MO
and that happened in Vermont and they
were saying oh well Ted Bundy was
definitely in Vermont at the time that
this happened so it's a possibility
killed an entire sorority by himself and
one night I mean he had no problem
taking multiple victims and what I [ __ ]
do you do something like that just
waiting a room waiting for him to come
home one by one yeah I just I don't know
I'm like I'm fascinated by this [ __ ] but
I can't I can't cook I can't like wrap
my mind yeah we've talked about that
before like Oh somebody's just like they
put it in their mind that they're gonna
go and slay this whole family yeah and
then they go and cook the [ __ ] steak
that they got I'm the frigerator yeah
what the [ __ ] right it's like and yeah
and that's the next top-10 let's use Oh
families it got wiped out or whatever
reason yet this next one we actually saw
this one on unsolved mysteries the other
day and if you haven't seen our episode
where we did a tribute to the Roberts
Robert Stack unsolved mysteries we did
that too that's a hit show - everybody's
loving it - watch that and that was [ __ ]
I know I love that shot and that I still
do it's it the neighborhoods are good
but you know it's hard to replace Robert
Stack you can't update
[Music]
yeah you say you probably remember this
one this is Elizabeth Campbell and yeah
she was um she was that girl that this
one happened in 1988 and she worked at a
7-eleven she went to her boyfriend's
house they had a fight and then she was
like well you know drive me home and he
was like no so she goes and calls tries
to call her brother from a payphone like
at a truck stop or some [ __ ] because she
lived like 30 miles away from where the
boyfriend lived and then they never
found her so the weird thing evidently
her parents tried to report her missing
like right away but I guess in some
states if you're an adult what she was
then you have to wait 72 hours it's so
[ __ ] up a file a missing person report
which to me seems I don't know if
Florida has that or not but that seems a
little excessive yeah well I mean yeah
it's a thing where yeah they're a grown
up and like they can take off if they
want to but if you know their habits and
you know that that that they're not the
type of person that would do that then I
kind of feel like they should take that
a little bit more seriously but yeah so
they had to wait 72 hours but in the
meantime they went and looked for her by
themselves now the creepy thing about
this and I don't they mentioned this a
lot on the unsolved mysteries episode
was that there were a [ __ ] ton of
sightings of her later on and it was
usually but buying gas and they usually
said that like a bunch of people said
that she came in or a girl that looked
like her came in with an asian man she
was half-asian and he was holding her by
the wrist yeah and she wasn't like she
wasn't allowed to look up like if she
looked up he'd be like they still found
this girl no they still haven't she's
still missing so they don't know if
those sightings are accurate because see
that that's the thing that kind of
muddies the waters of a lot of these
disappearance
cases is that you know somebody goes
missing they publicize it which is good
but then you get like all these people
calling it going oh sorry I'm sorry
there and a lot of times it's not them
and I don't think that people are trying
to be you know trying to be [ __ ] or
trying to as a chance disrupts the
investigation but sometime they might
see somebody that looks like them and
they get all excited and they want to be
you know they want to help there's a
chance that this girl got taken by that
trucker what was his name whips and
chains the ones that would not the toy
not the toy box Kilohana
he was a trucker that would go around
and he would put these girls into the
back of his little sleeper cab yeah
watch him for days yeah and kill him you
got caught what was his name
I can't remember but anyway that [ __ ]
make [ __ ] stick yeah you got this shot
so yeah this is this girl she's been
gone since 1988 I actually kind of tend
to believe some of the sightings of her
just because so many of them were
independently reported they were always
at gas stations and but it although it
seemed weird that if somebody had
kidnapped her and didn't want anybody to
see her why you know why'd he go to [ __ ]
why did he go yes there what you know
why do you bring her with you yeah you
know why don't you like leave her in the
car although maybe he was afraid she
would run away truth I don't really know
but they never did they never did find
her either so um yeah that one was on OC
it was the ice maker
there it goes alright so that was that
one that was on unsolved mysteries I
can't read who is this season one or
season two I think episode that we saw
that one on and I wanted to feature that
one just cuz that creeped me out too but
the truck driver got her yeah maybe
because one hit one of his victims he
took a victim and killed the boyfriend
of the victim and dumped that boyfriend
off in the place real close
to where that girl came that came up
missing so yeah okay there was some
physical evidence that links those two
cases I kind of gotta watch truckers man
and yeah that trucker he was the one
that took a picture of that girl she's
got her hands up like that he shot her
right before he took that picture or no
I didn't shoot her was threatening to
shoot her
he ended up killing her with a damn wire
wired her up to a tree and used that
wire around her neck and the tree it was
bad they said he strangled her too that
her neck was just down to her just a few
inches with that oh poor little like 17
year old runaway girl damn you kept her
for a little while like I said the
trucker's man well it's just you know we
were like remember we did a thing on
that episode a while back where they
were talking about they had figured out
like the most common jobs of serial
killers and trucker was in there well
because it's you know it's it's a job
that's conducive to serial killing
because you're always gathering yeah cuz
you're always on the road you can pick
up hitchhikers or testicle bone I think
those statics came from data that was
mostly from the 70s and 80s anyway maybe
it's not happening now yeah well like I
said you know and I think we mentioned
on there all right
they'll they'll maybe do some business
with an occasional lie lizard you know
but you know man's got to do he's got to
do you know but they're not killing
people they're just regular guys right
I'm just saying I grew up with a guy
who's now trucker he was an [ __ ]
dated my whole argument he's so drunk
you guys know it's funny though yeah
this next one was actually this happened
in British Columbia Canada
this happened in 1991 the creepy thing
about this is name was Michael Wayne
dunna he the weirdest thing about this
was that he disappeared pretty much in
sight of his parents like it was broad
daylight they were at this school ground
where the mom was like on some kind of
like ladies football league or something
like that and they were having a game
there that day so she was playing in the
game the dad was in the stands and the
son was just like he just went over
there to play for a second and he
totally disappeared no sign of him no
nothing so obviously this had to be an
abduction because there's no way that he
could have just like wandered off and
then they couldn't find him because they
started looking for him like pretty
crazy big rape rape person got him right
away yeah so they were kind of saying
that a couple people did say that they
had seen a guy in his late 40s or early
50s kind of hanging around the
playground and he had a brown van yes
they always have brown yeah two socks
with the three stripes pulled up around
them please do not use this as actual
leads in the case
yeah it's just making stuff up in it
curly hair
sandals he he looked like Napoleon he
had a white field you surprised he had a
brown van and not a white van yeah cuz
they always have white bands it's it
used to be white but now it's brown that
was some fancy from his comb [ __ ]
yeah must be I guess how it goes now the
only lead they've had in this case
happened in 2009 and they actually found
this guy in Milwaukee named Vernon seat
and he had a poster of Michael Donaghy
in his house which they thought was a
little odd he was 62 years old at the
time now he evidently had confessed to
his psychiatrists that he had killed a
child in 1959 when he was 12 years old
and that he knew of another one but
wouldn't tell them who it was there's no
one you know it's not forgotten oh all
these child murders yeah I remember we
killed yeah I killed back when I was ten
we didn't know happens to a kid you know
yeah child murder it's alright yeah well
that guy I mean if that guy did it I
don't know but he's dead now they yeah
they the weird thing is that the the
Wikipedia page says he was later found
dead by Milwaukee police apparently of
natural
things like the cops are like oh natural
causes I don't know how that could have
happened Wow
yeah now okay this next one I've said
okay I've seen this up like a lot of
blogs this one is pretty creepy this guy
is in Brandon Swanson this actually is
fairly recent this happened in 2008 now
he was a college student and he'd been
out at a party with his friends they
said he'd had a couple drinks but he
wasn't drunk or anything yeah now he so
he's driving his car home cuz it was
quite a long way and he he didn't wreck
his car but he just kind of ran off into
a ditch like the the tires were like
kind of up off the road and he couldn't
probably like move the car he college to
sky he did yeah
[Laughter]
yeah so he's he's fine like you know the
car is fine he was really so he calls
his parents now he's talking to his
parents on the phone for like 45 minutes
and he says okay well I kind of [ __ ]
up the car can you guys come pick me up
and he said that this happened in
Minnesota that he was near this city
called Lind and he was trying to tell
the more he was he's like oh I see this
light from the city and that's where I
am and so his parents drive out to where
he thinks he is and he's not there but
you know they're on the phone with him
the whole time and they said he sounded
totally normal and everything like that
but then all of a sudden forty seven
minutes into the cell phone call he
suddenly says oh [ __ ] and then the call
disconnects
yeah and then they have no idea where it
was now the creepy thing that when they
like pinged his cellphone like to see
where it was he was actually 25 miles
away from where he thought he was which
they couldn't figure out how that
happened how he could get so lost
they're like he's like I said he'd had a
couple of drinks but they're like he
wasn't drunk and his parents had been
talking to on the phone for like 45
minutes and he said he didn't sound
drunk he wasn't confused you or anything
like that so we don't know how he could
have gotten so lost they did eventually
find his abandoned car and there was
nothing out of the ordinary it wasn't
wrecked it wasn't there was nothing
wrong with it they are like they you
know they searched with bloodhounds now
the bloodhounds they went out I think it
was like a three-mile radius they went
into this like a stream or a river so
they thought it well maybe he just fell
in there and drowned but then they came
the dogs came out the other side and
kept on going and besides they you know
they dragged that whole body of water I
was in a big body of water I don't think
and they never found anything so this
got like they have no idea what you know
they're they're like the parents were
still his cellphone was still taking
messages so obviously he didn't like
fall in the river with the cellphone and
because then the cellphone would be
broken so it was still working but just
all of a sudden for him to just go oh
[ __ ] and then they never hear from him
again and for him to be so far away from
where he thought he was that they
thought that was just very strange so
this guy bills like I said this is a
very very popular case because because
of that phone call I mean you know
somebody just like oh [ __ ] now I think
most of the investigators are probably
saying well maybe he's just like in the
dark he stumbled and fell in the river
and
you know and we just can't find a jack
with some crazy woods person you know
yeah I mean it could be its Johnson
things [ __ ] to do it like I was yeah I
know seriously if anybody's from Iowa
tell me what that is about like why am i
fighting in the country but yeah why am
i finding so many unsolved murders in
Iowa I really need that explain nothing
I'm thinking it might just be because
you know it's like some states don't
really keep a huge yeah
tally like a huge website you know but
you know New Hampshire does Iowa does
they have there's a really good law
hangin out there yeah keeping track of
everything they're not overwhelmed some
of the other places are pretty
overwhelmed yeah maybe that's what it is
maybe maybe the other places have so
many there's like what [ __ ] we can't
even keep track anymore [ __ ] promote
at all like if you know [ __ ] I don't
know but you know maybe maybe in Iowa
they're like well it doesn't happen as I
was pretty damn boring
come on yeah but there's a lot well the
weird the creepy thing about Iowa is
that a lot of the murders seem to be
just random motiveless like hey there
was just a woman at home one day and
some guy came in and stabbed her 40
times and Larry Motum crime yeah not
rapes not robbed nothing they just like
I guess it's like wow yeah I guess so
that's what that yeah yeah if anyone's
thinking about it out there don't forget
that board just watch Netflix I haven't
finished mine yet you oh my god
isn't that like it I don't
it was such a nice bottle it is Coony
that's the Sam's like the Sam store
brand yeah blue is like your nail polish
Jenny yeah look it looks pretty on the
video it does it matches my bangs I took
my bag yeah my hair is real
[ __ ] yeah you can this is real
I mean extensions are fine and
everything but you could do this to your
[ __ ] her hair
actually is my hair
look I'm trying to cheer me up one day
and he had if he [ __ ] cut this hair
off and put it on her he's over there
filling up his giant jar to choke as you
go judge it's in the door right oh is
this one no no that's uh nope
yeah it was behind the almond milk we're
just we're all just like watching and
make a drink you're watching him
watching and yeah
you
okay now this one I I have weird
feelings about this this actually kind
of seems like someone that staged it but
I don't all right all right this one
happened in 1961 in Massachusetts oh
yeah all right
this woman's name is Joan rish this
happened in October 24th 1961 now her
husband got up and left the house he was
going to Logan Airport he was going to
New York City for a business trip takes
like 15 minutes by the way
yeah it's yeah that's right there now
right after he left Joan gets up she
feeds the kids she takes her kid across
the street to play with the neighbor
kids and you know she just says normal
[ __ ] she goes to the dentist she goes
the department store buy some stuff no
she goes to the department store the
department I said yeah she goes to the
drycleaner nothing and nobody notices
anything out of the ordinary so she
comes home with the kids she makes them
one she puts the kid one of the kids
down for a nap take some and then one of
the neighbors brings the other kid over
and then she takes both kids over to the
neighbor's house and it was like okay
well hang on
just watch them for a little while
people have to do that motherfucker's
yeah it's a it was funny were you just
kind of we can play outside - and yeah
yeah we just walked to the store
everything drank out of the tap oh I
still do that you still used to be
kiddin Cape Verdean what I'm drinking it
was but now yeah alright so let's see so
okay so it's like 2:00 in the afternoon
the neighbor looks out the window and
sees Joan and it says she looks like she
has a trench coat over her clothing and
she's like walking up her driveway like
kind of quickly like and it seemed kind
of specious and then she looked like she
was carrying something now an hour later
somebody sees like a strange car that
they didn't recognize in the
neighborhood like right around that
woman's house then she says that she
goes back over to drop the kids off then
one of the little girls comes back over
and she says mommy is not in the house
and the kitchen is covered in red paint
yeah and the baby was like in the room
and he was crying because he saw it a
diaper and it was falling you know there
was nobody there so to change it it was
hanging low yeah it was so in the
kitchen they find a few bloody smears on
the walls and overturned table and the
wall-mounted telephone has been ripped
loose and thrown into the wastebasket so
at first this is kind of weird like at
first they didn't necessarily think oh
she's been murdered they thought she'd
committed suicide for whatever reason
and this they started looking for her
body and they don't find her so they
basically are like okay well they call
the cops they call around all the
hospitals they're like maybe she was in
an accident and the creepy thing too is
that a bunch of people later saw her and
they said it looked like that she was
kind of she looked kind of disheveled
like she had put on like a cloth coat
and she looked like she was carrying
something and she was like walking down
the side of the road one person said
that she had blood coming down the in
down of her legs the amount was like
Mainstreet when I was a little kids in
my neighborhood yeah but yeah so they
said that um you know she wouldn't have
had all that much money left but I saw
sounds like my name yeah but they said
that the amount of blood they found
there like it was alarming but it wasn't
enough blood that it would have been
like you know that she got stabbed to
death or anything like that so the weird
so the weird thing they they see her
walking down the street she looks all
kind of [ __ ] up a couple of people saw
her like she had a little handkerchief
like tied over her head and stuff and
they said there was kind of blood most
of it was in the kitchen but then there
were like drops of it like a couple of
them going up the stairs it was one in
the windowsill in the kids room there
was like little smears of blood like on
outside of her car which was still in
the driveway and they said though that
there were no bloody footprints though
which they thought was kind of odd there
like it was there was a couple of finger
prints but no you know and which they
they didn't know if they were her
fingerprints because she wasn't there
like to get finger and she had never
been fingerprinted before so they didn't
know so they said you know it's Type O
blood they said yeah she had type O
blood but so do half of the people in
America so you know there was no way
they could figure that out now one thing
that kind of makes people think that
perhaps she staged a disappearance was
that for whatever reason I think because
of a tip or something they checked her
library records and she had checked out
a bunch of books over the summer mostly
true crime type of books which you know
nothing wrong with that but some of the
books she had checked out kind of
described someone that faked their own
death I think there are disappearance
info and anyone yeah and then leaving
like blood behind like this
you and animalism [ __ ] look at but then
you said it was Type O so listen a
person yeah yes sir me yes so I'm
thinking maybe she she gave herself a
White House cut and was trying it's a
whole procedure huh it seems like a lot
of trouble though I'm just saying it's
like if you just want to leave your life
just leave some people though it's like
when they went off to their own little
shop I'm asked you a question
what the person wants to disappear okay
why would a person want to hear such
lengths because I make it look like it
was because I'll play because it makes
it that way yeah maybe they're keeping
up with it later on you know they want
to be on they want and they want stacked
they want to stack okay well and I was
thinking too that another thing that
might have happened was that maybe she
got wounded accidentally and then got
disoriented
why was she scurrying down the driveway
though with her I liked her babushka and
I'm very young she she [ __ ] up when
she tried to be slick and then she was
just oh [ __ ] I'm not slick but I'm still
gonna pretend I mean the one thing that
now her husband is dead now and he did
not like to talk about it but he held
out hope that she was still alive I mean
he thought that that probably she had I
I'm thinking because of the books and
stuff and because one of the books she
checked out had almost an exact same
you know almost that same scenario where
it's like this woman was like I'm gonna
I'm gonna get out of here and I'm just
the leaves and blood so it looks like
yeah I mean like I said yeah in a new
little Susan's gonna be oh it's gonna
make the papers wife so once I get into
my new location I'm gonna be all about
my dad look at me all day I mean one
reason to fake your death I would think
because you have a current [ __ ] life and
then you want to move you know something
you have a [ __ ] life and they do have to
leave I'm not doing wrong some people
[ __ ] life I need to go yeah but some
people are just stupid
Julia Roberts Senate sleeping with Ana
me where she like faked her death that
she was like oh my wit no she was she
had yes yeah and she had to change her
name just like you know that in that
situation okay yeah so I don't know if
that kind of [ __ ] was going on in her
life maybe her husband was right that's
why I mean it's like so so you don't
know maybe it was something maybe it
wasn't you know maybe it wasn't just
kind of a thing where I just want to get
out of here maybe it was like I need to
change my name and so and cuz the
husband's not gonna become like come out
and be like well you know I was a
[ __ ] and so she didn't leave me
because it has he was it may be her
husband was an [ __ ]
[Music]
[Laughter]
can't understand it
I can't understand you
I can't understand
this is the Springfield 3 Suzanne
Streeter Stacey McCall and Cheryl
Leavitt now this happened in 1992 Susie
Streeter was 19
her friend Stacey McCall was 18 they had
just graduated from Kickapoo high school
[Music]
this is probably an Indian name but come
on use discretion high schools yeah come
on oh yeah I school Kickapoo yeah it'd
be sick you know I wouldn't know I'm
wondering what their sports team is
named mm-hmm the dummies probably get on
that Kickapoo high school you change
your name all right so yeah so Susie and
Stacey 18 and I feel like I said they're
so they're kind of going around
different graduation parties yeah
Kickapoo as you do with this shaking yep
yeah we getting
okay so Susie and Stacey they're going
around of different parties and stuff
like that and then they go to Susie's
house where Susie's mother Cheryl also
lives now Cheryl is 47 years old a
cosmetologist now at some point during
the night all three women disappeared
cars were still in the driveway most of
their stuff was still there
you know the all their purses and
clothes that's like that's mad unlikely
Yeah right
so that you know the friends come over
the next day and they're all gone
because they were supposed to go to a
water park with their
there are other friends so she came over
and no one was there so the weird thing
so the friend goes in because the door
wasn't locked and there's like there's
some really no sign that anything bad
happened other than the house being
unlocked other than the car being all
they're all their stuff is there
now while the friend whose name is
Janelle and the boyfriend are at the
house being like where the hell that
these three women go the phone rang and
Janelle answered it and the guy on the
other end of the phone it was an obscene
phone call sure so yeah she is just like
okay so she just hung up and left they
weren't really thinking about it
so then Stacey's mother comes over to
the house and you know door the house is
unlocked so she goes in now she sees
that her daughter who was Stacey that
her underwear and t-shirt were gone but
the rest of her clothes that she had on
was there they said that the girls had
come home and taken their makeup off
because it looked like you know there
was stuff in the bathroom that looked
like they had taken their makeup off so
they've probably taken their makeup off
and gone to bed and then for some reason
they just disappeared the TV was on
there was a voicemail on the machine but
she accidentally deleted it while she
was trying to listen to it
it took about 16 hours and then finally
the parents Stacey's parents reported
Stacey missing and so like I said forty
seven-year-old woman and two teenage
girls both God so but you know no sign
of anything else weird now the only
suspects they had in this case was
Cheryl who was the mother that
disappeared who was 47 she also had a
son named Bart and he had evidently got
into an argument with with her and the
sister because he was an alcoholic and I
guess they were calling him out on it so
he kind of got all upset about it but he
had an alibi they also suspected maybe
it was Susie's ex-boyfriend had done
something to them you know he had a rap
sheet for vandal as you know vandalizing
stuff
and yeah crap like that stealing corpses
gold teeth wait a hold on and selling
them yeah cuz I guess people want to buy
them I don't know dead body to get a
couple of gold for maybe maybe it was in
Iowa and they didn't know there was this
other guy though his name was Robert
Craig Cox he was an Army Ranger he had
been arrested and convicted in Florida
for another murder but it was later
overruled because they said oh there
wasn't enough evidence to convict him we
should have convicted him so he got out
oh that's it cuz it was Florida was
alright yeah so in this guy in 1985 was
convicted of two separate abduction
attempt and he eventually ended up
serving nine years in prison but then
later yeah he got out he was paroled and
he actually was paroled in 1992 and went
to live with his parents who lived in
Springfield Missouri which is where
these three women disappeared from so he
was right there right place right time
so right so maybe but you didn't yeah
and there was also a connection because
they found out later that this guy had
worked with Stacey's dad like a Stacey's
dad owned a car lot and so this guy had
worked there so he knew him so it wasn't
like it was just like a stranger and
really his only alibi for the time of
the crime is from his girlfriend and you
know how that goes
yeah he was available time right yeah so
he and he actually was kind of a douche
like when they put him in jail for
something else well I mean you kept well
yeah he kept telling the police he's
like oh I know where they are they're
dead and you know I know where they were
buried and all this other kind of stuff
but they didn't know how seriously to
take him because he was kind of one of
those attention seeker right you know
I'd confess into all this and not the
other so yeah so this case is pretty
much you know other than that guy they
have no other suspects no idea who took
these three women how it happened
because crazy struggle no blood no
nothing are you gonna kidnap people and
get nine years in jail like you
shouldn't be allowed oh why the hell are
you amongst people you kidnap people and
you get another [ __ ] chance no no
yeah you should be [ __ ] you should be
pickaxes with a dull ass pick you should
be digging yeah yeah so yeah so the
three women have now been declared
illegally dead as of 1997 but they never
knew what happened I don't know what
happened yeah oh this one I think this
is though this is the tenth one I think
this one is Dennis Martin and he was six
years old this happened in the Great
Smoky Mountains in 1969 it was Father's
Day weekend and they were yeah him and
his family were all out on a camping
trip and it was a trip they took every
year they went hiking in the mountains
inside so evidently they stopped in this
meadow that you know it was kind of a
popular place where people that camp
there would go it's like on the
Appalachian Trail and the all the
grown-ups were sitting out on the grass
like how had a picnic or whatever
they're talking and Dennis Martin he
also had a brother and there were two
other boys that were with them on the
trip and they said they were like oh
we're gonna play a joke on our parents
we're gonna you know split up we're
gonna go out in the woods and then we're
gonna jump out from all from behind the
trees like in all different directions
right there six
so they so three of the boys go one way
Dennis goes the other way and they all
like hide behind the trees and so the
the three boys they do what they're
supposed to do and they jumped out but
then Dennis didn't jump out so then
they're like well maybe he just didn't
hear us saying Hage about you know what
I mean
but they go over there and look and he's
gone and it was like great I mean it was
right there so so obviously the you know
the family kind of goes out in all
directions and they're looking for him
they find pretty much of nothing there's
absolutely nothing no sign that an
animal got him no sign their person got
him no nothing
the weird thing a few hours after he
vanished there was another family that
had been hiking about six miles from
where this original family was and they
said that they thought they had heard a
kid screaming so and also they thought
they saw something moving like in the
bushes and something was and then they
somebody said they thought they saw a
man that had like a bag over his
shoulder that looked like there was
something in it so they don't know if it
was like the kid like he had put the kid
in a bag or something like that or that
he had thrown the kid over his shoulder
this but one witness said that they saw
something like that but they just kind
of saw it in the corner of their eye so
yeah so they they never ever found any
trace of this kid either
[Music]
I'm wondering well like I said I don't
know you know yeah so you know they had
the whole the whole nine yards
bloodhounds helicopters everything weeks
and weeks go by they're like they found
a couple weeks after he disappeared they
found some little kid footprints
then they found a pair of boys underwear
near where he disappeared but the kids
mother said that they weren't his
although you know I don't know if they
were or not but she did not think they
were so I think it was the ice maker
actually so those little kids six man
yes six years old and it's just like
that's so creepy though it's not playing
a game and yeah just out with your
friends and then like a minute later
they're like totally yeah it's totally
gone so they don't know if a person got
on her animal got him
the it's this case is kind of well known
and I think that it's kind of one blog I
saw they kind of went off on this whole
you get taken by aliens or something I
do I don't know I was like reading some
of it I was just like really I just okay
I'm not so so I didn't think he got
kidnapped by aliens but I'm just saying
there are a couple uh there are a couple
blogs out there that are kind of going
into that conspiracy theory area where
they're just be like well they must have
been you know you must have been taken
by it because we can't tie it it has to
be aliens because obviously that would
be only that's the only thing right your
cat was took untick taken by aliens
briefing deposited behind the screen of
the computer it yeah it wouldn't
surprise me I for a while I thought she
had been kidnapped by a time like that
where could she possibly be
I thought she jumped that back fence I
don't think she can reach that she
couldn't go as a whole yeah there's a
hole underneath it
that's what I meant by jump that she
knows better that's alright want me to
go reach out her we found her it's fine
don't don't panic we wanted to get her
back on the show but she was just kind
of like I don't know she's like no
all right so I think yeah I think that's
a that was our 10 creepy disappearances
how [ __ ] long did that take holy crab
forever
you
now and of course you know the man we
got yes and you know we are already
watched James Bond if they hadn't seen
Casino Royale and I informed them I said
you know I'm breaking up with crustle
and I'm breaking up across well I think
I'm gonna hang out with the Craig oh
yeah I've seen bonds so many times that
I think my man my man crush is
transferred from the crustle to the
Craig Cross was gonna be mad at you it's
gonna be alright we'll see what happens
there's a testosterone factor I can't I
can't resist that [ __ ] it's just too
[ __ ] man it's just a degree in the
crystal sphere damn it's okay I am
totally going to I'm if you guys have
seen Casino Royale the very famous shot
of Daniel Craig coming out of the ocean
with his little bathing suit on so I
want to recreate that I want to make
Tom's come out of the ocean
with a tiny speedo hey I don't have
those abs you I don't have those abs not
yet and this gives me an opportunity to
talk about Casino Royale and I'm so mad
that I forgot to mention this on our
review of it evidently and this might
have been in the UK like I know we have
some UK listeners and maybe you can tell
me if it was UK if it was another
country I just assumed it was the UK but
they actually sold for a time when
Casino Royale came out like a popsicle
that was in the shape of Daniel Craig
coming out of the ocean for my age why
would someone make that up
that is so I was like wow that's very
specific yeah I wondered who like
decided to do that like the marketing
plan it's like yeah we'll have well
create came out of the water like that
with those abs and they had a lot of
people I guess male and female wanted to
sub that that's yeah maybe they kind of
like a chocolate bunny type of thing so
you could you know you're into that kind
of stuff too but yeah please tell me if
that's true I don't think they ever sold
it over here I never saw one not like oh
yeah Jimmy wahs one yes don't send me
one it'll be melted by the time it gets
here I'm gonna make you one don't worry
about that I got this [ __ ] on a control
I just you know I met water now because
I might as soon as this just are
throwing I'm I hand it back on over to
shot it again because Shawn did such a
good did such a good job basically she's
ugly she's Argus she's our guest host
for tonight you know I mean that allows
me to sit down there drinker like yeah
yeah yeah yeah right now before we price
shut this down because we had this
[ __ ] unrealistic fantasy that we
would be able to do ten lists of ten of
the [ __ ] we did one list the ten and
realize that was nearly two hours so we
cuz we just went on
which you know that's good keep it's
gonna like just a very long time - so
instead of having the magic number 100
we're gonna have the magic magic number
20 because you know we were motor mouth
when I went through it and it's pretty
good we're warmed up now we'll probably
put this at the very beginning because
the first segment we did the
introduction it just didn't it didn't it
didn't hit it didn't hit on all notes if
you know it wasn't firing on all
cylinders
we sucks just in case I have to
introduce did I introduce you get this
is yes sharp okay hey Sara Sean and Eric
Murphy they're friends of ours with from
Brockton man Brockton man we live down
here now but we're from Brockton Mass
yeah and I - holes and I was massive and
you know and of course I lived in the
Cambridge Somerville area for about four
or five years so I know Brockton well
you know so when I met them down here in
Florida and it was like yeah okay I
don't really I like Boston not yes I
don't miss them damn college the damn
snow either man yeah snow [ __ ] the call
and I would rather suelto yeah drink
some water
[Music]
okay you guys today you're going to see
the nerve center of 13 o'clock where the
magic happens let's check it out wow
this is Jenny's desk where she sits
every single day for 12 to 14 hours
working on various things
there's her water there's her aspirin
see that girl pictures up here got my
Domo got my Matic there's the microphone
that we used to record the show most of
the time there's my MST print there
there's another MST print there and in
case you didn't know here's my extensive
library this is where I get some of the
ideas for the show and these are all my
little Halloween toys that our cats like
to play with and carry around the house
there's my voodoo doll these are just
some various again it's all my MSD
episode there's all of Tom's exciting
Japanese robots he has more of them in a
second I will show you
there's yes use don't chose my Bauhaus
poster how well you can see that it's
kind of dark up there but there's kind
of lawyers a bunch of times toys there's
a poster of me from memento mori' more
about stuff yeah so for the hundredth
episode we just thought you'd like to
see where we sit when we're drinking and
recording and here it is thank you very
much and it's like well in its thank to
you because we like I said when we
initially conceived of doing the ten
lists we were gonna do half true crime
and half paranormal but then I only had
true crime stuff so I'm like now we're
like talking about creepy disappearances
and horrible murders and stuff and they
were just kind of like we don't mean to
joke about it but it's not a long time
ago to start off with this segment here
yeah this segment here is probably even
worse than the other one because these
are 10 massacres of entire family oh
okay all right and I'm specifically not
because we already did a show on hinter
correct farm the very famous mass murder
and they're you know I also did I did
like the Benny evangelist family and
stuff so I'm trying to do stuff that we
haven't done on the show before
so these ones are ones that have not
been done on the show before although I
should say that four or five of these
cases are going to be in my new book
when it comes out okay so if you're
interested in these cases they there
will be in the faceless villain volume 2
yeah and that's not that's not far from
being
it's a couple months probably yeah well
like I said I initially I was saying Oh
beginning of summer but it's since I've
been adding some more stuff to it yeah
this is a huge book and if you don't
have the first one oh my god good that's
it yeah pedaling is how it is it's it's
it you you won't be able to tear away
from it it rules yeah a book person and
I'm not a [ __ ] person so that [ __ ]
was the shit's cases that you never
heard before any of it just take it from
that [ __ ] was the [ __ ]
that's what we're gonna hang on the back
of the backside like the comments in the
books for like in a Siskel and Ebert all
right so yeah this is massacres of
entire families these are not in any
particular order and rank them or
anything like that first case okay this
is a creepy Kaiser I face and is what
you face in long train did not die in
pod me like me you're talking okay well
you're talking you blocked me lucky
lucky lucky this one I actually told you
about this lawyer walking I don't know
if you remember this happened in 1962
this is the maps family and I say the
entire family even though it was kind of
only the wife and the kid but I say the
whole family because they're not
entirely sure what happened to the dad
because he has never been found so this
is January 1962 the maps family consists
of the dad is Edward he's 39 he's an
artist he has a wife named Christine
she's 22 and they have a four month old
daughter named Julie Louise now they're
at their neighbor's house on this
evening they're having some apple pie
hanging out about nine o'clock they're
like okay we got to go home and put the
baby to sleep two hours later there's a
call to the firefighters and the
firefighters come to the house and it's
burning down pretty much so all the
windows are closed so the police bust in
there
now they find Christine Maps dead but
not from fire her skull was fractured
she was actually they say they found her
in the in the kitchen or in the room off
the kitchen it looked like she'd been
changing the baby's diaper and somebody
had come up behind her and hit her in
the head
she had so she was like holding like a
cloth diaper like up to her head like
trying to you know keep the blood from
County or something like that so so they
find her in the kitchen and that they
find the baby in the crib you know
pretty much already dead from smoke
inhalation yeah
so they took them both away the baby was
actually dead at the scene Christine
passed away a couple hours later now the
first thing they think of is well this
had to be the husband Edward maps
because he's gone like he's not in the
house anywhere and the house didn't burn
down entirely but it looked like there
was no accelerant in the house but it
looked like somebody had like set little
fires like all like piles of paper in
the hose and stuff but all the windows
were shut - so they said something that
didn't you know the fire didn't get
enough oxygen to really get that big but
they said that since there was no
accelerants it didn't look like somebody
had like plans to burn the house down it
looked like it just kind of happened so
initially they think okay well the
husband he you know he killed them and
then tried to set the house on fire and
then took off you know the gas stove was
on and with the door open and stuff now
there were a couple other weird clues at
the scene that they never really figured
out what they were or what they had to
do with anything
they said near Christine's body they
found a plate that had animal blood on
it and a woman's ice skate that was
covered with animal fur what now they
didn't have any pets so they couldn't
figure out where this blood or this fur
came from but it definitely was animal
blood it was definitely animal fur I
don't think they ever found the other
ice skate either they also found a
letter at the crime scene and it
appeared to be a letter that Christine
had written to the baby
who was named Julie Louise she's four
months old the letter says dear Julie
Louise we are still alive but the day
goes badly I still feel the squirrel
rage fantasy and baseless squirrel rage
fantasy yeah
Edward says you are the base but that is
unfair to you although much of my work
concerns you so they have no idea what
that means yeah creepy now another thing
so the husband
they're like notably all his [ __ ] was
still in the houses wallet all his
personal papers both the family's cars
were still there no what had driven them
away he was a sculptor someone had
smashed all of his sculptures which I
don't know why he would have done that
they said there was really no way that
he could have gotten away that quickly
at that time of night there were no cabs
or no buses there anything they didn't
he didn't take any of the cars now two
days later a friend of the family
around 8 a.m. they said that somebody
called them and they were sure that it
was Edward the dad and according to this
person
he says Edward says when you see Bob I
want you to tell him that I forgive him
now bob was probably Christine's father
whose name was Robert wall Bach now it
came out later on I mean the the friend
told Edward he's like we you know you
need to turn yourself in they think you
did it and evidently this person if it
was Edward said I can't do that I have
too many things to do he then said give
my love to Julia which their daughter's
name was Julie but Christine's mother
was also named Julia so I'm not really
sure who he was referring to and they
never established whether that was
actually Edward maps or not the front of
the family seemed to think it was but
you know that it was his word they
weren't really entirely sure so they
pretty much think that well it's him and
he just took off but the more you learn
about Christine's dad the more it maybe
sounds like
that guy should have been investigated
because Robert wall bak known as Bob he
hated Edward maps from the very being
like before they even got married and
evidently he thought that Edward was a
bomb he's like oh he's an artist he
doesn't work you know he doesn't have
any money he just wants to sponge off us
and all this other kind of [ __ ] and he
had actually threatened to kill him on
one occasion and admitted as much and he
had like popped him in the face and [ __ ]
like that now it did it turned out that
after Edward disappeared they found out
that he actually had a big trust fund
that his father had given him so he
wasn't actually sponging off anybody he
had money it's just that he didn't have
to work because he had trust money from
his family and pretty much everybody
else that knew him and knew that family
were like Edward would never hurt his
family it's like he was a nice guy like
he had some kind of mental problems
after he came back from World War two he
had served in World War two but they're
like not violence or anything like that
so they really didn't think that it was
him now
so as I said Robert Wambach was
Christine's father had they had just had
altercations you know him and Edward had
had altercations all the time there had
been fights he actually admitted that he
had threatened to kill him
Christine's mother also said that he had
threatened to kill her and started a
rumor that Edward and her were having an
affair which she denied so you know and
there was this other step about you know
him kicking them out of an apartment and
all this other kind of [ __ ] and
something that came up because at first
they thought oh well it couldn't have
been
Robert Wambach because he was on a plane
at the same time that the murder took
place
except they found out he was like oh
yeah I flew on Alaska Airlines to New
York City from Miami at this particular
time Alaska Airlines comes out and says
we didn't have a flight from New York
City to Miami that day so
and also he did actually get to New York
City later that day but he said oh I
checked into the hotel at like 3 a.m. or
something and the people who worked in
the hotel in New York City were like nah
more like 8 a.m. so see cuz back then
you know this was 1962 or whatever you
know you didn't really have to show you
just walk into an airport and like buy a
ticket yeah so you know no one looked at
any ID they couldn't really prove
whether he was on a plane whether it was
that airline but there was a different
airline but he wasn't on the airline
that he said he was on and he wasn't at
the hotel at the time that he said that
it was so but they don't really seem to
investigated him all that stringently
which i think is very weird because he
did have a very large property he did
have a really large really large
property and they never really searched
it so it's quite possible that he killed
the whole family that he took Edward
that he killed him later that he buried
him like out on the on his land or some
[ __ ] like that but they like I said he's
dead now so I don't know but they never
did find Edward maps nobody ever heard
from him ever again after that phone
call
the only other creepy thing was that in
1966 which was four days with four years
after the murder somebody left flowers
on Christine and Julie Louise's grave
and it was the day before Edward and
Christine's wedding anniversary and they
never found out who did that either so
they don't know if Edward did it and
he's still alive somewhere if the dad
did it and he killed all three of them
no one really knows so yeah so yeah like
this this case freaked me out and it's
weird because I feel like it's not it's
not as well-known as some of the other
like bigger
you know some of the other family
massacres like I said like the Hitler
cry factory farm and everything I mean
that one's creepy because that dude was
probably like living in their freaking
house [ __ ] like that but I mean this one
this one there's just lists so many
little details about it and I don't know
I I kind of suspect that it was probably
the father-in-law oh yeah yeah it's
sketchy that he lied about where he was
yeah yeah at that particular time but
yeah yeah
Alaska Airlines is like you were not we
did not have a plane going from there so
okay but let's see what's the next one
next one
this will happened in California this is
the bolds family does have an increased
line California this was 65 summer is 65
yeah thank you here we go you're facing
that in the in frame Jenni your office I
know but I'm trying to read and I can't
you know okay alright so this happened
in 1965 Jim and Arlene Bowles they had
two teenaged boys 13 year old Bobby and
12 year old Tommy they were originally
from LA but they actually wanted to they
were talking about you know building a
cabin out in Crestline out in the
mountains and moving out there kind of
getting away from the city and
everything I'm not sure if they were
building it as a vacation cabin or if
they were actually planning on moving
there
you know permanently there was kind of
conflicting details about that but they
had bought some land up there in the 50s
in 1955 but they just finished a cabin
in the summer of 1965 so the weekend
before the murder happened they actually
went up there and took a bunch of
furniture and stuff and then they're
like okay well next weekend we're gonna
come up here and we're just gonna relax
and everything's up here now so this is
the weekend of August 13th
sixty-five now the family they go to the
store they pick up the supplies for the
you know to go up to the cabin and they
drive up to the cabin now they're
supposed to be back on Sunday night
because they have to work the next day
but they don't come back
so you know both of the both the husband
and the wife moms are like flipping out
now there was a very large gap in time
because nobody could remember exactly
you know it's the 60s they didn't have
cellphones or anything so they're
calling the people's work and they're
like did they show up where are they
there was no phone installed at the
cabin yet the phone company hadn't been
there to hook the phone up and no one
could quite remember where it was like
they had family members that had been to
the land but it had been many years and
they couldn't remember where it was so
they had to kind of go all over the
place and get these peoples like where
is this cabin because there was a bunch
of cabins like in this area all right so
they get up to the cabin I believe it
was Darlene's brother and a friend who
was familiar with the area so they go up
to the cabin and they look in the window
and the first thing they see is a dead
dog someone has killed their dog and
left it on the couch yeah the couch yeah
it was like the dog was lying dead on
the couch the dog's name was Barbara you
ever you're the worst kind of person
yeah you should like that oh well yeah I
mean yeah anybody like what this is
funny because we were watching um what's
that movie John whit yeah where
everybody was talking about we went on
this big long revenge thing cuz somebody
killed his dog I was like I understand
that's like a memory of family yeah I'm
like I you know is
did something bad my cat it's a teacher
yeah I'm like you're in big [ __ ]
trouble hmm
yeah so they see the dead dog they're
like okay well this is this is not good
so they go into the house
there's blood like leading from the
living room into the master bedroom and
they see three of the family members the
dad and one of the boys and the mom like
just laying in pools of blood in the
master bedroom so they run out they run
to get the sheriff's substation and get
the cops to come now then later when the
cops come they also find the other
little boy who was actually underneath
his mother because it looked like she
had tried to shield him from the bullets
so yeah so he was underneath her but
yeah they found all four all four of
them were killed with a 22 caliber rifle
now there was a lot of weird things
happening around these cabins and a lot
of the you know I don't want to get too
much into it like you know in my book
and it's like a huge long thing like a
timeline and everything you know people
saw weird cars you know people saw weird
people there's like over there was a
party going on at a cabin that night so
no one would have heard anyone screaming
or heard gunshots because the party was
really loud and they said it must have
happened sometime like late Saturday
night because you know people had seen
the family like just doing normal family
[ __ ] like you know all day all night
Friday and all day Saturday they were
you know farting around in the yard and
the kids were playing and stuff and then
by Sunday morning their car was gone and
then they later found their car like in
the woods like a little way away and
there was no blood in it or anything
like that but they found the key like
underneath it yes so they don't know
like who drove that there there was
another guy that lived around there that
I believe it was either late Saturn in
or early Sunday morning that he was
coming into his cabin and he saw this
red car it was a Dodge I think and he
like passed it and he said there was a
guy driving and he was like driving
really fast but he couldn't you know
give a good description of the guy so
they really have no idea like somebody
basically there was no nobody forced
their way in nothing like that like
somebody just walked in and shot all
four of them like herded them all into
the master bedroom and totally shot all
of them yeah so there were like I don't
know there was this one thing with a guy
that was he had been a cook at this cafe
that was right down the hill and
actually the family had eaten there on
Friday night when they first got into
town and the cook had gotten fired like
a week before he was he had been in
prison for sex offence but they didn't
really specify what it was
why do you yeah you came out of prison
then yeah well they don't know they
don't know all the details there and
even know what he was in there for i
heard sex offense well I kind of well
this is the 60s and I thought the
imitating true I thought the implication
man he didn't public but yeah so do
[ __ ] because they said one of the
conditions of his parole was that he
couldn't get into any relationships with
men okay I was gay
the law so that was a condition of his
parole and apparently he did get into a
relationship with one of his co-workers
in this restaurant they fired him but
evidently on the day that the Bulls
family came into town and we're eating
at this restaurant one of the girls that
worked there like a wisher she saw him
like in the parking lot and she when he
was like watching them but they don't
know if it was I mean you know they
don't know if it was him but they did
think it was weird that he was like
hanging around like even though he
didn't work there anymore and you know
something had some false confessions
they had all this other kind of [ __ ]
happen but um there was one guy that
they looked into they got the cops and
Crestline got a message from the cops in
Mobile Alabama and they said there's
this guy named George Robert Stewart he
was a suspect in molesting and murdering
two little boys in Mobile and they
thought that he was heading out to
California because he had a friend that
lived out there and when they looked
into his past they discovered that he
had been working at a cabin like only a
couple miles from where the vols cabin
was Oh at the time that they were killed
so they thought it was some religious
camp or some [ __ ] now they actually did
end up catching him in Texas and he said
yeah I was in that area at that time but
he's like oh I would never I never
killed anybody
he seems kind of they said he was kind
of um he seemed kind of slow you know I
mean so they couldn't they weren't
really sure now he seemed kind of
offended that they would have implied
that he's like I would never hurt a dog
cuz they said you know did you go and
kill a dog and kill his family
he's like I would never kill a dog I
would never do that I'll just oh no II
I'm sorry you know yeah innocent until
proven guilty
yeah so that guy I mean they could never
find enough like evidence to pin it on
him and actually he never got arrested I
don't think he ever got arrested for the
double murder in Mobile Alabama either
cuz I don't think they ever had enough
evidence for him there so they don't
really know they're like I said no
motive really I mean I'm sure there was
a motive but they don't know what it was
and yeah so somebody just walked into
this cabin and shot the whole family
today that's what you do I guess take
them all out and the dog like I said
there's no telling what that was all
about yeah it's like something something
a kid would do it sounds like something
like a 17 year old boy would do you just
found a gun and it's like you know what
I'm gonna wipe these people out
something something crazy so like some
stupid just to see what it was just to
see what it was like that kind of deal
all right now this one this happened in
our my home state of Florida which you
know you'd think there'd be more of
these from Florida Florida man yeah
Florida is still awesome there isn't
there's an amount of Awesomeness to
Florida there are still prehistoric
birds here people yeah they try to get
into my house I got a [ __ ] on video oh
yeah they knocked on the windows well
because you're accidentally fed water
you're not really supposed to feed them
there because they're very loud and they
know they're smart man they do not
forget they don't forget if you feed
them once they will become a knock at
your door yeah and then they'll come and
bring their children via him baby
the baby give me some yeah okay
so this actually I'm gonna tell a Hasse
Florida this is the Sims family they
this family was originally from
Mississippi
well they you gonna be okay alright so
they so they had just moved to
Tallahassee from Mississippi Robert Sims
was 42 director of data processing for
the Florida Department of Education his
wife Helen was 34 and she worked at the
nearby church she was a church secretary
and she also played the organ of the
piano there yeah and they had three
daughters 17-year old Jenny which sauce
in my name but you gonna tell them what
durably older they know what your name
is
[Laughter]
alright 16 year old Judy and 12 year old
joy now this happened in 1966 it was
October 22nd and Tallahassee there was
like a whole bunch of people in town
because it was like a huge football game
yes Seminoles where's the Bulldogs yeah
so ed so everybody's and everybody's
there so Robert and Helen are at home
they're watching the game or listen to
the game on the radio or whatever their
youngest daughter joy is at home with
them their other two daughters were out
babysitting for you know people that had
gone to the game for babysitting reason
is for babysitting reasons so Jenni Sims
she finishes up her baby babysitting job
first babysitting
because you know how so she comes home
at about 11:15 she goes in the house and
it's all dark in there dark and quiet
and she goes into the master bedroom and
sees her father lying across the bed
bound and blindfolded a big pool of
blood on the bedspread underneath him he
had been shot once through the head
Helen Sims it was on the floor like a
laying and an angle also bound
blindfolded covered in blood she had
been shot twice in the head and once in
the leg 12 year old joy lay beside her
mother still in her nightgown she had
been tied up shot once in the head and
stabbed six times in the chest so the at
the time see this this is one thing when
you're like researching cases a lot of
particularly the girls under age they
didn't like to say if they were sexually
assaulted I guess so some you know some
sources of this case that I said said
she was and son said she wasn't mmm but
her underwear had been pulled down so
they there was something sexual going on
and it's like you know she was only 12
so they wouldn't really say so they said
actually there's a really good
documentary about this called 6:4 I
think it's called 641 Muriel Court drive
because that was the address and it goes
into like a lot of detail about it but
the crazy thing about this is I guess
Tallahassee at the time they didn't have
the whole 911 you call another one you
get an ambulance
so Jenny Sims calls the funeral home
because the funeral home like doubled as
the ambulance I guess so yeah Bevin's
your home which is just nearby so they
came there and then they got the cops to
come there now there's been a lot of
criticism because they think that the
cops just kind of came there and
travelled all over the crime scene
because they were just all laissez-faire
about it they're just like you know
whatever I don't need gloves I don't
need this and that which you see a lot
like in the 50s and 60s
yeah it seems like they didn't really
have that whole forensic everything down
there just kinda like I'm just gonna
touch stuff I'm gonna wipe it on my ass
so you know I don't think it was that
bad but I just don't think they really
were all that stringent yeah
but um yeah so they didn't see there was
you know no no four century no didn't
appear that anything had been stolen
there was no struggle they just figured
somebody had come in and like herded
them all into the bedroom and killed
them now one of the people that they
thought this was I mean the first
suspect and actually some people in
towns still think that it was him was
the pastor of the church where Helen
Sims worked his name was CA Roberts or
Cecil Albert Roberts now he was known as
something of a player like he was a
womanizer he had like a lot of affairs
and he was always like hitting on women
and stuff so they kind of thought well
maybe do that yeah so they thought well
maybe he made a pass at Helen and she
told him to get [ __ ] or you know maybe
she was threatening to like he maybe he
was up to some sketchy [ __ ] and she was
gonna tell everybody about it because
she had quit her job only a couple days
before she got murdered
so she said funny but it turned out that
he had pretty much the best alibi you
can have he was actually the team pastor
for the Florida State Seminoles and he
had been at the game and he was on tape
the whole time they said the only time
that he wasn't because he was standing
on the sidelines so it's like you could
see him in the whole entire TV broadcast
they were like the only time that you
couldn't see him was halftime and
they're like that they there wasn't
enough time for him to have let the game
gone and murdered the whole family and
then
come back because he's there like he was
still standing there like it this thing
so yeah so they said even though he you
know [ __ ] around and you know kind of
made passes at women stuff and he kind
of had a reputation for that but there
was no way that he could have killed
anybody however the the rumors about it
actually ruined his career and he had to
move away so yeah because you know even
if you didn't do it now the weird thing
about this and I don't want to go too
much into it but evidently I was reading
a blog post about this and one of the
guys that's like the prime suspect is
still alive and he's commenting on their
now they think that him and his
girlfriend his name is Vernon Fox jr.
and his girlfriend at the time who he
actually later married but their divorce
now her name was Mary Charles Lajoie and
they lived in that neighborhood and
people thought they were kind of weirdos
like she was sort of into I don't want
to say necrophilia but she was kind of
into like she would go to the funeral
home and like connive I would have steal
the burial shrouds and she was like one
of those kind of evil and and they kind
of had they didn't really have a motive
specifically like they didn't really
know the Sims all that well but there
were rumors that Vernon was kind of
weird and then he would like peek in
people's windows like he'd been reported
for like peeping and stuff even though
he denies it and like I would never do
that because there were rumors that he
had been peeping in the window looking
at their twelve-year-old daughter joy so
he was kind of like come out is like no
I like older women I don't like little
girls so he put the creepy thing like I
said is that when I was researching this
case and I'm like reading all these
comments like on this blog that was
written about him like oh my god that's
him he's talking about it and he's like
had he had all this information about
like no this is what happened I did this
I did that like on this particular day
and my ex-girlfriend or ex-boyfriend
she's crazy and she's just trying to
although I do kind of feel like the
girlfriend is kind of a nutcase and like
I said if you go find this documentary
about it like I said it's called 6:41
Mario Kart drive there is an interview
with him he sounds a little sketchy too
but there is footage of her from the 90s
because apparently after the two of them
got divorced she immediately went to the
police and said Oh Vernon did it so
they're not real sure if maybe she was
just mad but she went to the police and
she talked to them for like six hours
and they recorded all of it and she
sounds like a little bit of a whack job
sort of so I I don't yeah so I don't
know if it was just her if both of them
did it cuz she kind of sounds like she
might know something about it
like the way she's talking but she the
way the way she was talking it was like
she knew just enough like she could say
just enough like to not get in trouble
right but you know what I mean she was
just like well what if like what I'm
like one of the weird things she said to
you was that when she was talking about
Vernon like going after these girls and
you know one of the 12 year old is dead
right and she's like that little girl
was so ugly oh I went like that like
when I serves I'm like you did not just
say that
oh my god
I'm just talking about what an ugly
little girl she was it's like I don't
know why
Vernon liked her she was so she was so
ugly she was 12 years old
oh she just likes a creepy [ __ ] like
that it's like seriously go watch this
documentary about this it's crazy
oh and there's interviews with this
Vernon guy too because of course he
denies it but his stories kind of
changed over the years it's little
details yeah like he's always kind of
like oh his story is that he was walking
home cos him and his girl see what had
happened was that's his story okay they
went to the movies which they did
because like the ticket taker saw them
and everything like that they went to
the drive-in but he says that when they
came home like she dropped him off and
he was walking back to his house and
then this car passed him and there was
two guys in it and they opened the back
door and we're like oh hey get in
oh wait you're not the guy so his whole
story is that these were hitmen like I
said it was either him in the girlfriend
or it was just the girlfriend honestly
cuz that girlfriend you can get the
whole like six hours of my ass to
motivation I'm gonna but then I wait a
bit of it doesn't menti own his name in
the document I have to see this jet so
this is like some crazy [ __ ] oh and this
guy and this Vernon Foxx guy comments
awesome
he comments on blog posts about this
case and it's learn it's creepy that mmm
I know and it's weird because it's like
this is Tallahassee Florida it's like
I'm from Florida
but I had never done this case ever and
apparently it's pretty yeah let's just
stop it just there's already enough bad
[ __ ] Vernon come on Vernon all right
let's move on to the next one
this is the brita family 28 year old
Jerry his wife Linda who is 23 and they
had a four year old daughter named
Debbie they moved to Green Township in
1963 which is right outside of
Cincinnati
Jerry actually worked it sounds like
it's outside of Cincinnati doesn''t
Township just outside of Cincinnati
Township
quaint yeah all right so Jerry work for
Monsanto he was a chemical engineer now
Linda she used to work as a flight
attendant but then after she moved she
just took part-time work at a veterinary
clinic there neighbors said they seemed
like totally nice normal people they
said they kept counted to themselves but
not in like a creepy weird way or
anything like that they said you know if
their little girl would play with the
little girls in the neighborhood like
that had to you know the same age or
whatever so then comes the morning of
Monday September 26 1966 what's going on
in the 60s now these are I know I know
if we were talking about this the other
day I'm like it seems like you know
everybody's like oh violent blah blah
but I'm like yeah the 60s were bad they
died they all know it was it yeah like
the flipside of that was firing wilt oh
no it's the truth right here on 13
o'clock
it's Jesus [ __ ] most of the worst [ __ ]
was like sixties and seventies easily
you know [ __ ] look no forensics you can
get away with killing people family
isn't [ __ ] yeah it was a cool style of
murder
people get away with it right you could
just walk in and kill a bunch of people
I'm like no no all right so it's Monday
morning September 26 which is my
birthday in Stanley Oh
but but so the neighbors are noticing
they're like wow Linda never brought in
the garbage cans they're like and she
always does that they're like and we
haven't seen any of the family since
Sunday night but nobody goes over there
yet because they're just like oh maybe
they just want somewhere it's whatever
but then they notice you know the day's
going on you know none of the kids come
out to play you know their dogs don't
come outside you know no one picks up
the newspapers so then finally on
Tuesday night two of their neighbors
come over and knock on the door nobody
answers obviously the door was not
locked they opened it and all a neighbor
was wafted overwhelmingly out toward
them oh Jenny oh yeah they opened the
door and they they knew that they were
all dead they could smell it and so they
said we're not going in there we're
going fine they went to the cops so yeah
all right so here we go Jerry and Linda
they had both been bound and stabbed
multiple times
Jerry been stabbed nine times in his
neck and back also been gagged with a
sock which had been taped into his mouth
Linda was stabbed eight times in the
chest plus she had a bunch of little
cuts on her face she hadn't been raped
though they don't think they found the
four-year-old up in her bedroom in her
pajamas she was stabbed four times and
the person had the knife had gone all
the way through her own or times yeah so
it was like this really long bladed
knife so they figured okay so no sign of
forced entry no nothing was stolen no
sign of a struggle the dot they had two
dogs but the killer had sedated them and
locked them in a room like in a separate
room to keep them out of their way gone
dogs just you wait a while
okay what yeah I'm gonna go ahead and
kill your whole family but you dogs
[ __ ] I'm gonna shoot the dog too and
this one were like they took the trouble
to like put the dogs in a separate room
and but I mean the four-year-old the
foyers got a go with you dogs so yeah
yeah they never found the murder weapon
and they thought that maybe what the guy
did was that he took one of the
newspapers from the front yard that the
family didn't pick up and wrapped the
knife in it and then put it out in the
garbage because the garbage was
collected on Monday so yeah now at first
they thought well they they actually had
had a serial killer in Cincinnati called
the Cincinnati a strangler in operating
in the area at the time but the mo was
not similar and you know it was kind of
a distance away so they thought probably
that wasn't who it was then they thought
maybe I think the main culprit for this
was the veterinarian at the clinic where
Linda worked there were rumors that she
had been having an affair with him but I
don't yeah I don't know how accurate
those are some people that work there
said oh yeah we saw them together you
know in the cars and stuff his name was
dr. Leininger fred Leininger they did
question him and he was kind of like
evasive a little bit not not so much
about the murder but about the affair
he's like no no it's just a professional
relationship or whatever um people
admitted that yeah but then after that
he wouldn't cooperate with the authority
more oh no vet Oh bad luck the doggie
away
lawyer yeah yeah no yeah not an
admission of guilt
the dogs are okay though just a
[ __ ] covenant covering his neck
now one of the weird things about this
case is that one of the Britta's
neighbors
nettie Caudell she knew Linda pretty
well the - she had a little girl about
the same age and their little girls to
play together
she said that Linda had been acting kind
of weird like for a month before her
dead like kind of nervous like she
thought something bad was gonna happen
and then it turned out that she had
known these two flight attendants that
had worked for United Airlines Lisa wick
and Lonnie Trumbull that got murdered in
June of 1966 in Seattle and so the
neighbor said she talked about that a
lot so she wasn't sure if like she
thought she was gonna get murdered just
because these two girls that she knew
got murdered or if that had anything to
do with anything but they just said that
was kind of odd because she had worked
with those two women even though it was
a totally different city so there were a
couple of other kind of related crimes
to it there was one a girl named Valerie
Percy who was actually stabbed in her
bed in her house with with her whole
family there and they never caught the
person that did that either and they
thought maybe there was kind of a
relationship there because they thought
maybe the two families knew each other
kind of traveling the same social
circles but you know they don't know
about the connection there either but
this again is a case where that's just
like most of these cases where they have
no idea
like why any why anybody
all right so this next one this is a
pretty well-known case the case of the
Robeson family it's probably better
known as the good heart murders this was
another one that kind of happened in a
cabin although this happened on Lake
Michigan this happened in 1968 again
[ __ ] 60s I guess well like you said it
you get into like yeah alright so it's
July of 1968 now this guy named Chauncey
bliss he like runs this place called the
bliss wood resort where all of these
vacation cabins are all these neighbors
start complaining that there's a bad
smell coming out of this particular
cabin that belongs to this family called
the Robeson's he thinks it's just a dead
animal but of course he goes in there
and it's not a dead 42 year old ad
executive and magazine publisher Richard
Robeson had been shot five times in the
22 caliber semi-automatic rifle well it
took five times the bullets to fired
through the through a window of the
cabin yeah he had also been beaten in
the head of the hammer oh damn
Richard's wife Shirley who was 40 years
old she'd been shot several times the 25
caliber semi-automatic pistol which
should be suggest two perpetrators
probably the couple also had four
children
19 year-old Richie 16 year old Gary 12
year old Randall and 7 year old Susan
and all been shot in the head of the
same pistol and it killed their mother
Susan had also been bludgeoned with the
hammer so by the time they found the
bodies they were really decomposed so
they thought maybe that they had been
killed about June 25th so they'd been in
there for a while
Shirley Robinson's body was posed that
they didn't specify and I haven't seen
the photo but they said they'd been
posed to suggest a sexual motive um but
they weren't sure if she'd been raped
because the decomposition factor so they
didn't know if it was just some red like
if they wanted to staged it to look like
that they found some shell casings they
found a bloody shoe print
they thought what happened was the
killer came up and started shooting
through the windows and then came around
to the back door which was unlocked now
the first guy that they thought it might
be was this guy named Joseph scelera the
third he was thirty years old he had
worked for Richard Robeson at impresario
magazine which you know because the
Robeson was magazine publisher now this
joseph´s Calero guy apparently embezzled
about $60,000 from the company now some
people said that on the day that the
Robeson's were last seen that Robeson
had been on the phone with somebody and
he looked like he was upset so it could
have been that he just discovered the
embezzlement and he called Scolari I was
like hey what the [ __ ]
and then scholars walk along just gonna
you know I'm gonna come and kill you
Skol arrow also was known to own two
guns of those particular calibers when
they tested these shell casings they you
know they couldn't specifically say that
that was the exact but they said it
could have been and they always and I
love this too they always give the same
story it's like whatever they're like
well you have a gun that is the same
caliber as this gun that was used to
shoot this family's like oh yeah I used
to have one but I lost it yeah yeah I
lost it I lost it or they always say
that or I lost it in a craps game or I
sold it or something I was holding them
so that was it yeah it's like they
always say that kind of lost now he said
the interesting thing too is that okay
school are oh he had a pair of new shoes
and the soles of the shoes looked a lot
like the bloody footprints but the shoes
that he had were new like they hadn't
been worn so they don't know if he had
another pair just like it that he threw
away and he just bought it on the credit
or replace it or
whatever but these like these were the
same shoes but they had like a similar
sole now he told the cops I was in
Detroit at a plumbing convention when
the family was murdered which he
could've been but nobody there like
remember him like he couldn't find any
he couldn't find anybody I know they
didn't look at each other's pipes I know
that's really gotta be a good name don't
I'm not trying to it's Lemmons plumbers
you are necessary we love you when you
guys [ __ ] [ __ ] piled up in your house
the most important [ __ ] in the
world was a Palmer man I got [ __ ] my
house yeah so yeah so this guy it's like
you know it see there was some
circumstantial evidence but they didn't
have enough physical limits they didn't
think they could pin it on him so you
know he if he did it he got away with it
the only other guy I think they ever
really looked at was there was a serial
killer named John Norman Collins and he
actually got convicted of a one murder
in 1970 but they think that he did a lot
more murders and abductions and [ __ ]
like that that they never pinned on him
so they're like it could be him there's
not really much of a connection but it
could have just been a random murder
evidently skull ro was pretty much the
prime suspect a couple years later it
was 1973 there was a new chief
prosecutor and he said I'm gonna get
that guy I'm gonna go I think I have
enough to pursue a conviction and then
scelera shot himself oh yeah so it's
officially still an unsolved case he did
there made sense well he wouldn't solve
the case now didn't I guess
motive I mean you know he stole that
money from the company evidently man all
right he went in
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
okay this actually happened in 2000 it
was December thirty first two thousand
and this actually this was the set of
Gaea family forty four-year-old Mickey
oh Jesus Miyazawa his 41 year old like
wife Yasuko and their children eight
year old Nina and six year old ray
discovered murdered in their house on
December thirty first two thousand by
yasuko's mother Ray had been strangled
the rest of the family had been stabbed
this is a creepy little detail there's
an analysis of the crime scene conclude
the family had been murdered on December
30th after which the killer stayed in
the house for several hours using the
family computer and eating ice cream
that's like I'm but like I'm not I'm not
saying like that's worse than murdering
the family but they got all the family
and [ __ ] put a cherry on top hey hey
ice cream yeah ice cream yeah hey it was
there I get horrible horrible yeah use
the computer looking at the poor oh yeah
there's like dead people in the house
and it's like oh I'm gonna go get some
moose tracks he also left numerous
articles of his clothing at the scene as
well as the two knives which were using
the killings [ __ ] so what do you leave
the house naked arrived oh he wore some
clothes out of that [ __ ] he went are
you worse one clothes over like another
set of glue oh he's an [ __ ]
now yeah so a taxi driver who is go by
says that he picks up three middle-aged
men around the time of they thought the
murder was and he said that the guy left
behind blood marks on the back seat of
his taxi
so yes says the investigation into the
murders is among the largest in Japanese
history involving over two hundred forty
six thousand investigators as of 2015
forty officers were still assigned to
the case full-time yeah oh I love this
this is a disgusting detail but you guys
know how much I love that police
determined that the killer had eaten
string beans and sesame seeds the
previous day after analyzing feces from
the killer in the family's bathroom
Danny didn't flush yeah he's just piling
indignity upon and dignity he kills an
entire family this rugged [ __ ]
yeah their house he takes a [ __ ] in
their house and wash it it's like what
the [ __ ]
so yeah so yeah this dude is still at
large and and this guy this happened
fairly recently so they might still be
able to get this guy and now they have
DNA they they have DNA - [ __ ] and
everything oh my god they need to put on
solve mysteries on this yeah yes baby
that his mother is probably European
they knew that from DNA okay yeah they
said he killer has a mother of European
descent possibly from a country near the
Mediterranean or Adriatic Sea
The Killers father is of Asian descent
with the DNA appearing in one in four or
five Koreans one in ten Chinese and one
in 13 Japanese he's believed to be about
170 centimeters tall and it's been
billed because they can tell that - from
your DNA also they can tell what you
look like
have you seen that they can do that
if they have your DNA they can actually
do like a reconstruction of exactly what
you look like yeah cuz I've seen that
they've started doing that recently
designer babies on the way to way they
probably got him already yeah yeah
Chinese probably buy them this is that
this is the hope I'm pronouncing this
right the green Oh family or the green
off Emily this is this happened in
Australia and these were ax murders this
happened in 1993 which is kind of recent
for an axe murderer you don't see a lot
of axe murderers anymore now this one
they actually know who did it
the victims were Karen McKenzie she was
33 and she had three children named
Daniel who was 16
amara who was seven and Katrina who was
five and they kind of lived out in this
rural this farm kind of area in Western
Australia and this was February 21st
1993 now they know that they were killed
by this guy named Bill Mitchell and he
was just like a friend of hers nice
[ __ ] friend right okay this says on
the date of the crime Mitchell had been
spending the day getting high on a
mixture of cannabis alcohol and
amphetamines listen stupid [ __ ]
you know never mind you don't need to be
intoxicated to be a [ __ ] [ __ ] and
we are humans we all have the equal
propensity to Benham stupid [ __ ]
or a nice [ __ ] don't blame the
weed the alcohol or the enemy
[Laughter]
and I love that this write-up says the
trouble began with you know with the
sound of a car the trouble that's a nice
way of putting into [ __ ] unmask began
with the sound of a car arriving the
McKenzie home Daniel who is one of the
kids went out see who it was and was
confronted by Bill Mitchell and Bill
Mitchell was apparently really mad about
something he wielding an axe killed
Daniel and headed for the house where he
found Karen asleep in the lounge room
after attacking her with the axe and
killing her he then raped her after he
killed her yeah that's how they does
have those [ __ ] do it that's
how they [ __ ] do it I don't underst I
don't understand it you got to have a
serious problem
yeah yeah that's also quite an
understatement
yeah so then he so then he goes upstairs
and kills the other two girls as well so
I guess this guy had been a farmhand
um I'm not super sure what the motive
was he's an [ __ ]
you just yeah he just got really upset
one day but he actually did get
convicted of the murders in 1995 he was
only 24 years old when he got convicted
he did yet for concurrent terms of life
in prisons he did yeah so alive [ __ ]
yeah yeah evidently I guess some at
least he was caught yeah and you know
evidently there was a big outcry cuz I
think at first they were thinking oh
well give him parole after however many
years but then career
yeah but yeah he out you whatever the
[ __ ] yous you know the fleet that
[ __ ] college kid that break that
[ __ ] girl [ __ ] you so the next one is
the Dardenne fish oh yeah yeah I just
read my notes like right here like if
you're but yes go be our rice shot yeah
yeah yeah I know what it was that you
read yeah
all right this is the Dardenne family
this happened on November 18th 1987
police were called to the mobile home of
Russell Keith dirty and who is 29 and
his family outside ina Illinois after he
failed to show up for work that day
there they found the bodies of his wife
and son both brutally beaten
Ruby Elaine Dardenne start 30 who had
been pregnant with a couple's daughter
was beaten so badly she went into labor
and the killer or killers also beat the
newborn yeah so okay and the killings
had apparently taken place the day
before investigators at first believe
that Keith and dad was the prime suspect
however that theory was discredited the
next day when his body was found in a
nearby field he had been shot and his
genitals mutilated his car was found
parked near the police station in Benton
Illinois I do was pissed off and further
yeah so yeah I didn't like this yeah
this one's kind of depressed this one
they think might have been a serial
killer named Tommy Lynn sells he's
actually in prison out for some other
[ __ ] and I
he either confessed to this and then
recanted or you know so they kind of
think that he's probably the one like I
wrote this a long thing about it but I
don't really want and that's like yeah
pretty pretty sucky right now yeah okay
we had audio problems right here so
we're gonna have to spoon this in we're
gonna head do a little repair jobs like
a little patch if it is this case it
this is the case about the kids that
were trying to get to convergence right
yes all right now check this out check
this out guys this entire okay I was
involved in this case
well sort in a way not was that I was at
that convergence where did we see this
story first time we saw like a whole
documentary about this [ __ ] right it
wasn't on unsolved mysteries because
it's solved yeah I was at that
convergence in New Orleans when that
happened and some goth kids said hey Tom
hey Tom do you know some kids were
trying to come here and they killed some
people on the way yeah that's it really
yeah there were religious people I
started there started preaching to him
in the shop yeah I was like those
[ __ ] [ __ ] it was exactly that was
like and I was a manís shit's gonna come
down on us and it did yeah that's yeah
yeah yeah this is um gelila lid family
yeah and this actually happened this
happened in 1997 in Tennessee now there
were these six kids from Kentucky and
they were mostly like teenagers 14 - you
know however old and they were um they
were living in this [ __ ] town yeah
bad place and they were kind of those
kids where it's like I'm gonna wear all
black and I didn't quite know this other
kind of so they kind of tried their hand
at being a goth boy even though even
though they weren't really part of the
scene and there was no internet really
to speak of at that time just maybe
those [ __ ] probably couldn't even
forward WebTV really remember web TV
yeah that's a long time ago yeah I do
remember
and you know they were living kind of
bad lives and they wanted to get the
hell out of there and go to convergence
which is this big goth party where
everybody from around the world used to
converge on it it was in New Orleans
that year I was there yeah I lived in
that area during that time I knew people
that were helping with the event man
when this [ __ ] happened it was kind of
like blowback from it ya know what I
mean because this is in the area was
right after all those they shot up
Columbine I was gonna say yes a bunch of
stuff coming down and it was hard being
goth and back in the day I mean you know
people would try to kill you they would
throw stuff at you have the windows it
was just it's not like it was today
these kids they got it easy
they do kind of you old-timers know what
I'm talking well because back in the
back in the 80s people didn't really
have any frame of reference
nowadays everybody knows oh it's goth
you know I didn't know what it was back
then they didn't know what that was
they knew what Marilyn Manson was and
they didn't like it and that meant you
were one of them yeah they would come
after you they'd always talk about
Marilyn Manson and we didn't really know
all that much about Marilyn Madden he
wasn't really the scene he was kind of
kind of had attached himself to the
scene yeah he's from here isn't he yeah
matter of fact a good friend of ours
knows him that's right yeah he's from
the Orlando area I don't know if he's
from ryr originally but yeah I've heard
a lot of stories about him he's not a
bad guy just right now he's not a bad
guy but um yeah so there's basically
these six kids and they decide you know
oh we're all into devil worship as they
they mostly just did it to rebel it
seemed like to me so they're like we're
gonna go to convergence did they steal a
car I feel like they stole look I know
they know what happens car broke down
and they stole the place so we're gonna
carjack someone
thank you basically so then what I
remember so they stopped at this rest
stop yeah in Tennessee and they get out
of the car and they're walking around
and then also at the rest stop there is
a van yeah containing the liklihood
family right narrow Connolly's
bible-thumper time they were um
Jehovah's Witness
I think yeah and it was the dad's name
was
Vidar and the wife's name was Delfina
yeah and they were nice people yeah they
had a six-year-old daughter named
Tabitha and a two-year-old son named
Peter yeah and they were at this rest
stop and I guess the dad saw these six
kids like walking around and oh they
were wearing all black and they had like
crazy colored hair whatever and he
decided oh I'm gonna go over to save
their souls and talk to them like about
Jesus or whatever wrong move in this
case and yeah and it sucks because I
mean I'm I'm not saying I don't know I
just I I could kind of relate to it
because in those days man we would get
pestered by religious people oh yeah and
they would make a bunch of assumptions
about you based on how you were dressed
that you were worshipping the devil or
into drugs and and other kind of stuff
just all wrapped into one and it was
their duty to save you from sin
I guess although and they didn't really
know us you know so it's kind of like
they're just jumping to conclusions and
in this particular case these were some
fucked-up kids I mean that's what I mean
in this case they were actually correct
these kids were very messed up yeah I
wouldn't call him I wouldn't call all of
them bad just [ __ ] up they came from a
bad place they were mistreated a lot
they didn't really have anything and
they influenced each other in a weird
ways where they just kinda became this
weird almost like the Manson cult it's
kind of what they became they were kind
of like that they were mind but but
without really a Charlie to guide them
they just kinda made [ __ ] up as they
went along yeah and one of them it was
it was more than half of my believe
we're girls right can you actually name
which the perpetrators were Natasha
Cornett Dean Mullins Joseph prisoner
Crystal Sturgill or Sturgill Jason
Bryant and Karen Howell so yeah yeah
well yeah yeah well what I don't know
what happened roses that they just said
we just want your car and they robbed
and
and the boy I think was the boy that did
the shooting well see that's the thing
we know there nobody's really sure when
they all went to trial it was kind of
because basically this is what happened
they were they were like well but we
just need your car and the dad as you
would was just like we'll take the car
take the money you know just leave us
here it's fine right but of course one
of the kids I don't know who yeah was
just like no you guys all have to get in
the van now too and then they drove
these poor people out into the woods and
then just stood them all lined him up on
them up and just shot them bottle down
into the into the into the gutter
there's a little culvert there in the
south we don't really have gutters it's
just a little cutouts on either side of
the road for drainage you know it's
grass everywhere and they needlessly
mowed this family down when they could
have just taken the van and left that's
what I mean the guy like Peter little it
was totally like just he even like
offered them the money in his wallet and
was like just take the car you know yeah
it's fine it was a tragedy it was
horrible and it's like actually so then
they ran over the bodies as they laugh
and the little pin and there were little
kids with that fan that six-year-old no
two-year-old yeah and I think one of the
little kids did survive the two-year-old
survivors he survived but they wiped
that family a whole family nothing yeah
and it's just and the shitty thing too I
mean as shitty as this whole situation
is they so the six kids went on trial
for this and none of them would admit to
who was the shooter yeah it's like
everybody blamed everybody else for
being the instigator oh well we didn't
want to hurt anybody in a way it didn't
matter though because under American law
they were all they were all they're all
couples are all culpable so they all got
life in prison yeah they did I think
they they got like real life sentences
each or something for the people they
kill cuz like I said and they had a
charge of attempted murder too because
the one kid survived and they were very
lucky in a way they under most American
sensibilities of the South they should
have all gotten excavation of all but
received the death penalty yeah I think
they only just because they were young
or too young thought they were [ __ ] up
and everyone
but it's like what it didn't care I mean
I I kind of feel like it was mercy I
believe yeah what a life sentence was it
was merciful well some people some
people say that life in prison
might be worth worse than death sentence
yeah I guess it depends on who you are
but they executed that whole family I
think they had to be executed if you
asked me I'm not a proponent of mercy in
cases like that there's really I mean
there's no excuse that really I mean
yeah they were all underage but I mean
they weren't that young yeah
they know what they were doing with oh
yeah I know yeah you know they you know
they weren't that fun it was that they
laughter those religious people because
they just thought they were dorky and
then they took their [ __ ] and gunning
down don't do that it's like I just I
don't just don't understand that well
they were mistreated in the town that
day why don't you take the card we take
the car I can't like little kids yeah
what can you do that that's horrible
yeah they came from nowhere from a
nothing place and they were treated
worse than nothing their mental health
wasn't very good and there were no
prospects for their futures to speak up
so in a way this was them committing
mass suicide and taking a family with
them and again this is they they kind of
struck me two at the time and I think I
mentioned this on our Israel Keyes show
where they just have this real edge Lord
kind of attitude like oh I'm so even
here's the truth about it is that they
killed those people so they could get to
convergence where they thought they'd
fit in but if you'd saw they would never
fit in now everyone in the guy every one
of the Gaza yeah everyone everyone there
was dressed to the nines I was there
yeah everyone dressed to the nines there
were people in thousand-dollar outfits
you know they were from all over the
world Europe you know we had German
Goths there it was a good convergence
they wouldn't have fit in no they
wouldn't fit in they were basically just
wearing black t-shirts and black shorts
yeah everybody would have thought yeah
yes yeah they did what [ __ ] they which
they were they didn't really look the
type you know what I mean no like you
said it's it's kind of sucky that that
kind of [ __ ] gets tied in with the goth
see not so much anymore because people
understand it now but I remember well I
remember the 80s when nobody
knew what it was I mean everyone just
thought I was a Satanist but then after
Columbine and after this case you know
then everybody thought oh and her also
you're a serial killer I feel bad about
Columbine though had I been there I
could have prevented it yes I think so
all those guys needed was somebody to
think that was older than them that they
would have respected that if they had an
older gal said listen guys I know you
don't like your school in a few more
months you're gonna be [ __ ] out of
here don't worry about that [ __ ] they
those kids would have been alright if
you ask me that kills me that cop my
kids would have been alright just that
they couldn't invent they could not
imagine a world outside of school that's
right that amazes me still because I I
mean high school is just so nothing yeah
the grand scheme of things I know it's
important when you're going I know
somebody that went went to Columbine
High years before that four or five
years before that that happened and that
was a super yuppie school and they were
very cruel to kids that weren't yuppies
basically yeah healthy and that's what
happened to those guys they you know
they just had a vendetta against a that
community even though they had money
they had money it's just that they
didn't like that culture and I can kind
of understand you know the yuppie
culture is kind of annoying if you ask
me yeah but they were they they got so
pissed off at being picked on that they
were just gonna take the whole school
down when all they had to do is just
wait a few months and they de gotten out
yeah and then everything yeah their to
probably end up being cool guys yeah I
just got wrapped up they didn't have a
vision of the future and that's what
happens with some teens best yeah
teenage boys under the influence of
these [ __ ] crazy-ass hormones well you
get kind of wrapped up in your own
problems yeah and I don't think they
knew anybody older than them that liked
bands like kfdm you know they were into
that yeah they were proto they were
Konig ah they're more like goth
industrial type gosh yeah and I don't
think there was anything really wrong
with them it was just that they didn't
mix and that they didn't mix in that
environment and that environment made
him worse and worse and they just got
very uh hell-bent on revenge against
people that were they were never gonna
accept them anyway and all they had to
do just wait yeah you know but I guess
when you're that age
yeah I don't remember what it's like to
be in that age so I can't speak to that
anymore I don't remember high school
I don't really hardly there was a very
very long time it was Kevin and Dylan
you know they had a bad synergy between
the two you know they were driving good
sometimes they were driving each other
to heights and they were doing these
edge Lords you know yeah you get like
you guys together it's like if they were
by themselves if I would have done that
I probably would've been fine but yeah
they're just like you know egging each
other and if there was somebody who was
you know could have snap a piss out of
it so you guys are [ __ ] crazy you
know how to do that [ __ ] man just it'll
blow over and then they they could have
been defused
yeah they're just kids yeah true and it
might have been the same with the with
the Lilla lid slaughter also I mean if
somebody had actually befriended these
kids or hung out with them or you know
because they were very young I mean yeah
I don't know though I think that I think
the Senate never there was more of them
and I think this is there's like six of
them and I'm not sure how well you can
reach through them because I'm not sure
I could reach them very well there was
the kind of the socio-economic barriers
trio you know I mean like where they
came from was pretty damn rough it was
just one big trailer park and it was
like I'm broken down trailer park yeah
so they might have just they just saw me
with [ __ ] yeah thought I was anomie yeah
cuz you feel like you don't know where
exactly but yeah that's uh that's really
kind of a horrible shame how that
happened at least one at least one of
the kids arrived even though yeah family
got killed
yeah it's surviving family members
adopted the boy though
yeah yeah so it did work out yeah
there's my hearts out to that family the
surviving yeah that family there is
actually a documentary about when that
happened that was a waste yeah waste and
that was and the goth industrial
community of that time had nothing to do
with that they wouldn't like those kids
either no no of course not
the wolf family and actually somebody
requested that we do a show on this
so consider this our kind of show on
this because I needed one more to round
it out I said I was somebody else's to
do this on okay so let me see
alright this I'm not I don't remember
where I got this right up front from
it's not very long but I'm just gonna
read from that because my my voice is
going alright it was the families
abandoned laundry left flapping on the
clothesline that raised the alarm a
neighbor who came to investigate found
no one around odd for a busy farm this
is kind of sounded like hint or crack
isn't it he discovered the first bodies
in the barn hastily covered with dirt
and hay his neighbor Jacob wolf and two
of wolfs young daughters Maria and Edna
so they were all dead in the barn in the
basement of the house were five more
bodies Jacobs wife baa the rest of their
daughters Bertha Lydia and Martha along
with their hired boy Jacob Hoffer the
children ranged in age from 3 to 12 the
hired boy was only 13 they had been
killed with a shotgun and a hatchet the
only survivor the wolf's 8 month old
daughter Emma was crying and hungry in
her crib it was April 19-20 in the still
young state of North Dakota even a
century later it ranks among the
country's most brutal crimes so this was
a their yeah they were a German family
they had come from Russia and there's
actually and it's pretty creepy but you
can still see there's photographs of it
on the Internet they're grave marker
just reads the murdered family Oh in
German so weird so evidently at the
funeral for this family they said one of
them one of the mourners was behaving
oddly
Henry Layard who owned a nearby farm
opened each casket in turn and gaze down
Oh Beijing
what you doing baby the fuzzy Kitty on
the show the baby kitty won't be on the
show though miss yeah she's like yeah
okay so yeah this guy opened each casket
and turning gaze down at the face inside
[Music]
unusual he also raised suspicions when
he was discovered prowling around the
wolf barn by the Sheriff
he seemed eager to help yeah yo he's
gonna watch those kinda yeah yeah he
wanted to see what progress to the body
said maybe they just killed but they did
actually arrest him after a lengthy
interrogation he finally confessed to
the slayings and was sentence to life in
prison at hard labor he died in prison
just five years at five years later
after an operation for appendicitis yay
it was also a German who had emigrated
from Russia I love this he's like he had
a large family with six children in his
confession he said he had gone to the
wolf farm to confront his neighbor about
a dog that had bitten one of his cows
and it just got out of hand his cow was
probably an [ __ ] too now he says he's
like this is how it went down
he's like layer said it was wolf who
produced the shotgun a double-barrel
shotgun there was a scuffle and both
barrels went off the first killings were
accidental layer said and after that he
was quote in a fog
according to layers confession vieta 36
and the my boy what does that somebody
was it a murder fog
so he's basically saying why didn't mean
to shoot the entire first and that I
shot him then I just shot everybody
because so he says he accidentally shot
the wife and the hired kid but then
Jacob the dad he came and you know he
came running like hey what the [ __ ] are
you doing and then later shot him oh so
he meant to shoot him first and then the
other - yeah so have you saying that
after that yeah he just kind of kept it
and and he he like hit them with a
hatchet also so it's like wow I'm sorry
I yeah so he says yeah he covered the
bodies in the barn with hay and pushed
the bodies in the house through a
trapdoor into the cellar then he went
home to his own farm but in prison he
retracted his confession he said he had
been bullied into it and warned that he
would be turned over to a murderous mob
if he didn't cooperate all right yeah so
I don't think they ever let him out
though but yeah so the baby Emma who was
eight months old at the time of the
murders she was the sole survivor of the
massacre she was raised by an aunt and
uncle she lived a long life dying in
2003 at the age of 84 and that was yeah
but yeah that was the wolf family this
is a really that was a bummer all of
these stories are a bummer yeah I mean
that's what we do though that's that's
our show it's like we always do a bunch
of bummer [ __ ] and we try to we make
jokes about it but you have to make
jokes about it you might as well call it
murder of law because
yeah that's okay and that will do it for
our extra long extra special 100th
episode hopefully we will have a hundred
more if all of you guys want to come
with me why share subscribe like share
subscribe on all your social media if
you would like to support the show
financially you can go to our patreon
page at patreon.com slash 13 o'clock
podcast or you can go to our blog which
is 13 o'clock podcast WordPress com and
there's a link in the sidebar to a
PayPal account also please check out our
zazzle storage zazzle.com slash 13
o'clock up we have a bunch of t-shirt
designs there and also a tote bag that
you can purchase if you would like to
also check out our last movie review
which was the 1985 movie life force and
we will see you again next week on our
totally regular episode 101 Bajirao
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]